Hey guys, good to see you. Sweet look at my shots. Yeah. Anybody wearing underwear today? What up, Shoddy? Where'd you guys get those microphones? What up, Shoddy? What's Shoddy mean?
嘿，伙计们，很高兴见到你们。太棒了，看看我的镜头。好啊。今天有人穿内衣吗？怎么了，肖迪？你们从哪弄来那些麦克风的？怎么了，肖迪？肖迪是什么意思？
Let's not. Why is that? What is it? What's the difference? It's cool. What does Shoddy mean? Shoddy is the... No, Shoddy.
我们别这样了。为什么这么说？那是什么？有什么区别？这很酷。肖迪是什么意思？肖迪是……不，肖迪。
I think Justin Bieber says Shoddy, doesn't he? Oh my gosh. What does it mean? All right, it's an onus Marlis says Shoddy, doesn't he? Oh my gosh, short. What does it mean? All right, it's an all new smart list. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
我觉得贾斯汀·比伯说过肖迪，对吧？哦，天哪。那是什么意思？好吧，这是一个全新的……马里斯说过肖迪，对吧？哦，天哪，短。那是什么意思？好吧，这是一个全新的聪明清单。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey, Sean, do you have an understudy? I do, he's great, Max Roel, he's amazing. Now, have you given Max a chance to get up there and do his thing? Yeah, one night, well, so one night, remember,
聪明。聪明。聪明。嘿，肖恩，你有替补演员吗？我有，他很棒，马克斯·罗尔，他太棒了。那么，你给过马克斯机会让他上台表演吗？对，有一天，嗯，所以有一天，记得吗？
I changed smoked, right? I changed smoked on stage. And it made my vocal cords just massively inflamed. And I couldn't barely talk, so I was like, so I missed one show and he went on, he was fantastic. Oh my God. So now I took out all this stuff from the cigarette. So now it's the vape pen that lights up when you suck in, but it's just air.
我抽烟抽变声了，对吧？我在台上把嗓子抽坏了。这导致我的声带严重发炎。我几乎说不出话来，所以我想，我缺席了一场演出，他上台了，他表现得太棒了。哦，天哪。所以现在我把香烟里的所有东西都去掉了。所以现在是一个当你吸气时会发光的电子烟笔，但里面只有空气。
So I took out all this stuff. You're still sucking. I'm still sucking. Hey, I just wanted to get that audio clip. And can you copy me and then the file that I've got going of of these guys things. Is that a sound meme? I'm really punchy today.
所以我把所有这些东西都去掉了。你还在吸。我还在吸。嘿，我只是想拿到那个音频剪辑。你能帮我复制一份，然后是我一直在弄的这些家伙们的文件的那个文件吗？那是声音迷因吗？我今天状态真好，有点冲动。
I took a volume last night just so I could sleep and it's like, are you still up to it? Not work? No, it works. But I'm just like, hey, how's everybody doing today? So we just have like a loose bottle of volume hanging around. What on earth stand? Is there like the Luber drugs that you need as popover? Do you not understand how prescriptions work?
我昨晚吃了一片安定，就为了能睡着，然后就感觉，你还能应付吗？没起作用？不，起作用了。但我只是觉得，嘿，大家今天过得怎么样？所以我们只是随身带着一瓶散装安定。天哪，斯坦？是不是有什么你需要的那种自由药物作为压轴？你难道不明白处方药是怎么运作的吗？
Yeah. No, I take one every few weeks. What's the prescription look like on that? What do you mean? It's a volume. Yeah, but why do you have it? Because like if I have trouble sleeping like every several week, like I take one every couple months just to get back in the sleeping habit.
对。不，我每隔几周吃一次。那个药的处方看起来是怎样的？你什么意思？那是安定。对，但你为什么有它？因为如果我每隔好几周才有一次睡眠困难，比如我每几个月吃一次，只是为了找回睡眠的习惯。
That's a sleep aid, huh? For me, it is. Do you know what a sleep aid is, Jamie? Yeah, it's called, uh, what's it called? Um, um, um, Gunja. Gunja gummies, ambience, annex. I had not heard of the volume.
那是助眠药吧？对我来说是。你知道什么是助眠药吗，杰米？对，叫做，呃，叫什么来着？嗯，嗯，嗯，大麻。大麻软糖，安必恩，阿普唑仑。我没听说过安定。
Well, I'm calling JB last time I thought to Jason after seven PM is like, I read a man. That sounds I read. Let's talk tomorrow greetings in the name of his emperor. I said, I see I'm like, buddy, can you play golf tomorrow or not? No, Jay, valiums like it's the same family of Xanix and others. Oh, that's a real fun family by the way. It's like the Manson family that would accept me. No, we're saving a seat for you Sean. Oh, Sean, he had a good luck buddy.
好吧，我上次给JB打电话是在晚上七点之后，杰森就像是在阅读一个男人。听起来我读过了。明天聊，以皇帝之名问候。我说，我心想，老兄，明天能不能打高尔夫？不，杰森，安定就像它和阿普唑仑等药物是同一类的。哦，顺便说一句，那是一个非常有趣的家族。就像曼森家族会接纳我一样。不，我们给你留了个座位，肖恩。哦，肖恩，他祝你好运，老兄。
Hey, listen, I'm feeling really punchy tonight too. It's so hot out here on the East Coast. It's unbelievable. Can you get it cooler before I get out there, Willie? I don't know man. It's so, it's so, it's so hot out here on the East Coast. It's unbelievable. Can you get it cooler before I get out there, Willie? I don't know, man. It's so, it's so, so hot. It's a thick. Very thick.
嘿，听着，我今晚也感觉状态很冲动。东海岸这里太热了。简直难以置信。在我去那儿之前，你能把它弄凉快点吗，威利？我不知道，老兄。这里太、太、太热了，东海岸。简直难以置信。在我去那儿之前，你能把它弄凉快点吗，威利？我不知道，老兄。太、太、太热了。非常浓厚。非常浓厚。
And I was just riding my bike into town. And I was like, graph way there. I was like, this is a bad idea. It's really hot today. But anyway, I'm really excited, though, to be back here, to be back inside, to be talking to our guests. I'm excited.
我刚才正骑着自行车进城。骑到半路的时候，我在想，这真是一个糟糕的主意。今天太热了。不过无论如何，能回到这里，回到室内，和我们的嘉宾谈话，我真的很兴奋。我很兴奋。
Our guest. I am such a fan of our guest and I'm also a personal fan of our guest. It's better not be a classy guest. This is a funny bro. Well, she is. She's both. She's very classy and she's very funny.
我们的嘉宾。我是我们嘉宾的超级粉丝，同时我也是我们嘉宾的个人粉丝。最好不是一个高傲的嘉宾。这是一个有趣的兄弟。嗯，她是。她两者兼具。她既高雅又非常有趣。
And I think that she's started much more serious, just based on her credits and the movies she did and the show she did, and then started to get into comedy. And it was just an absolute home run when it comes to comedy, but then can kind of flip back and still do the serious stuff,
而且我认为她一开始要严肃得多，根据她的资历、她拍过的电影以及她演过的节目来看，然后才开始涉足喜剧。说到喜剧，她简直就是一个绝对的本垒打，但随后又能切换回来，依然能演严肃的题材，
which is really, if it wasn't so admirable, it'd be annoying, you know what I mean? It's all the while being like a really cool person. We've never really worked together, except for we did represent a country once together. And I'll explain that in a sec. So she's Australian, she's Australian.
这真的，如果不是那么令人钦佩的话，就会很烦人，你知道我的意思吗？同时又是一个真的很酷的人。我们其实从来没有真正合作过，除了我们曾经一起代表过一个国家。我一会儿会解释。所以她是澳大利亚人，她是澳大利亚人。
She's in the prime of Australia. I think we know her from so many shows. Rose Bird. I love Rose Bird. Yeah, I got it. I love Rose Bird. Hi Rose. How's it going?
她是澳大利亚的杰出代表。我想我们在很多节目中都认识她。萝丝·伯恩。我喜欢萝丝·伯恩。对，我懂。我喜欢萝丝·伯恩。嗨，萝丝。最近怎么样？
What are you doing? Is that a cute short haircut? Or we got it all up in the back? No, I'm just like a top nut. Well, you look how good you're looking to Bob. Yeah. You're looking at Bob. It does look like I've got a Bob.
你在干什么？那是可爱的短发吗？还是我们在后面全部盘起来了？不，我只是扎了个丸子头。你看你留波波头多好看。对。你在看波波头。看起来我确实留了个波波头。
What's it going? Hey, how are you? I haven't seen you for so long. Rose, where are you right now? Hi, friend. I'm in Brooklyn. Rose, where are you right now? Hi, friend. I'm in Brooklyn. Oh, Brooklyn, New York. Brooklyn, New York.
最近怎么样？嘿，你好吗？我好久没见到你了。萝丝，你现在在哪里？嗨，朋友。我在布鲁克林。萝丝，你现在在哪里？嗨，朋友。我在布鲁克林。哦，纽约布鲁克林。纽约布鲁克林。
I'm in East Coast. Yeah, I just got back from Australia. Yeah. The country we both represent. For sure. And that's all I've got to come about. Can we stop there? She allowed me to come along for the journey.
我在东海岸。对，我刚从澳大利亚回来。对。我们共同代表的国家。肯定的。这就是我所能想到的全部了。我们能停在那里吗？她允许我一起踏上这段旅程。
She was really representing me. Well, it's helping me. I was just just talking about. Rose, there's no shortage of really talented, handsome, funny men that are actually Australian. So how far down the list do you go before you hit American and then to get to will our net on the American list? So it's a spot that you both did a commercial that you did for travel to Australia, right? It was a campaign for, yeah, to the most Australia. Thank you, Sean. Just in case your audience
她真的代表了我。好吧，这对我很有帮助。我刚才正说到。萝丝，真正有才华、英俊、有趣且实际上是澳大利亚人的男性并不短缺。所以你在遇到美国人之前要在名单上往下找多久，然后才能把威尔·阿奈特列入美国名单？所以这是你们俩拍过的一个广告，你们为去澳大利亚旅游拍的广告，对吧？那是为，是的，去澳大利亚旅游的宣传活动。谢谢你，肖恩。以防你的观众
was confused, who gives a shit if they know what we're talking about, or not, when you come to this, they don't want to know everything. How do we cast Will Arnett and that rose? Well, it was just my voice. It was playing in American. The character is a, you know, this far in American who comes in. And it's of, yeah, it's just a, he's a unicorn. Yeah, yeah, truly. I am. And my character is too. Yeah.
感到困惑，谁他妈在乎他们是否知道我们在谈论什么，当你来到这里时，他们不想知道一切。我们是怎么选定威尔·阿奈特和那个萝丝的？嗯，那只是我的声音。它在扮演一个美国人。这个角色是一个，你知道的，一个深入其中的美国人进来了。这是一个，是的，他就像一个独角兽。对，对，真的。我是。我的角色也是。是的。
So you play an animated, you play an animated American unicorn. What a commercial. That's cool. Do you, do you do an Australian accent with it all? I mean, I don't really. I don't. I'm very good. No, I know.
所以你扮演一个动画角色，你扮演一个动画的美国独角兽。多棒的广告啊。太酷了。你在里面会用澳大利亚口音吗？我是说，我真的不会。我不会。我很好。不，我知道。
I know. No, I know. You can probably. Yeah, he does a very good one. Do it. Just a little. Give us a little. Come on.
我知道。不，我知道。你大概可以。是的，他做得非常好。来一个。就一点点。给我们来一点。来吧。
You're in front of the green screen. Shoot son. There's a. Oh, that's a knife. You love doing the knife one. Oh, yeah, that's not a knife. This is a knife. Yeah, that whole thing.
你站在绿幕前。开枪吧，孩子。有一个。哦，那是一把刀。你最喜欢用刀那个梗了。哦，对了，那不是刀。这才是刀。对，就是那一整套。
That's a bell. I mean, I get it. Oh, yeah, that's not a knife. This is a knife. Yeah, that whole thing. That's a bell. I mean, I get it. But then it becomes a whole thing about the dinghy when it ate my baby and all this sort of stuff. I don't want to get a track here, you know. Because then, wait, what movie was that for? Wasn't that Nicole Kidman?
那是一个铃铛。我是说，我懂。哦，对了，那不是刀。这才是刀。对，就是那一整套。那是一个铃铛。我是说，我懂。但后来这变成了一个关于小艇的整体事情，当它吃掉了我的婴儿以及所有诸如此类的事情。我不想在这里偏离主题，你知道的。因为后来，等等，那是哪部电影里的？那不是妮可·基德曼吗？
No. No, Merrill Street. Merrill Street. Merrill Street said with a straight face. They're a really famous but very infamous case in Australia about a woman who was jailed for murdering her child, Lindy Chamberlain. And she tried to blame it on a dingo? Yeah, well, and they didn't believe her and she became this sort of national kind of
不是。不是。梅丽尔·斯特里普。梅丽尔·斯特里普面不改色地说出这句话。澳大利亚有一个非常著名但也很臭名昭著的案件，关于一个因谋杀孩子而被判入狱的女人，林迪·查amberlain。她试图把这归咎于野狗？是的，好吧，他们不相信她，这成为了全国范围内针对她的一种
witch hunt for her and then she eventually was acquitted many years later. But it was a famous film with Meryl Streep. And that being line was in her big defense. And the big things, yeah, defense was a big thing. A cry in was and her big defense. And the big things. Yeah, defense was a cry in the dark. Yeah, it was. It was sort of enough
猎巫行动，然后多年后她最终被无罪释放了。但这是一部由梅丽尔·斯特里普主演的著名电影。那句台词就在她的大力辩护中。而重头戏，是的，辩护是一件大事。哭泣是一个，在她的大力辩护中。而重头戏。是的，辩护是《黑暗中的呼唤》。是的，就是它。这可以说是
sterling equivalent of, of where's the beef. I think I think it was not a comedy. She said that seriously. She found the laughs. Merrill found the was a very serious case.
斯特林的等同物，相当于“牛肉在哪里”。我想，我想那不是一部喜剧。她是认真地说出这句话的。她找到了笑点，梅丽尔发现那是一个非常严肃的案件。
And we're not downplaying the the. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, such a cool, you're such a cool, fun person. And so exactly what I hoped you would be, which is like, super down to earth and cool. And I was like, and super talented. And you're like, wow, some people got it all. And then, you know, I work with these guys and some people have none. So, but the point is, it was just such a delight to get to know you. And I'm such a fan of everything you've done, which is a lot. And when I start to go through all your thought,
我们并没有淡化那个……不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，你是一个如此酷、有趣的人。而且完全符合我的期望，那就是超级脚踏实地又很酷。我就想，而且超级有才华。而你就想，哇，有些人真是应有尽有。然后，你知道的，我和这些家伙一起工作，有些人什么都没有。但重点是，认识你真的是一件非常高兴的事。我是你所做的一切的超级粉丝，而你做过很多。当我开始浏览你的所有思想时，
it's going to say, except for. No, I was going to, so what happens is when I was getting, knew that you were coming on today and I'm going through all the stuff, I'm like, oh yeah, Rose, isn't that? Oh yeah, Rose, isn't that? I mean, you have made countless films and television. I'm making the hay guys, making the hay. You've got to keep dancing. I'm really not just crunching.
本来想说，除了。不，我本来要，所以情况是这样的，当我准备，知道你今天要来，然后我浏览所有的资料时，我想，哦，对了，萝丝，不是那个吗？哦，对了，萝丝，不是那个吗？我的意思是，你拍过无数的电影和电视。我在开玩笑，伙计们，在开玩笑。你得继续跳舞。我真的不只是在咬牙坚持。
So what was the first one? What was the first one? What was the big, what was the first professional gig that you can remember? The first job I got paid for, I did this movie called, Pretty Strange Little Movie, called Dallas Doll, not to be confused with Debbie, Dallas, Dallas. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
所以第一部是什么？第一部是什么？那部大的，你能记住的第一个专业工作是什么？我拿过薪水的第一份工作，我拍了一部电影，一部奇怪的小电影，叫《达拉斯洋娃娃》，不要和黛比、达拉斯、达拉斯搞混了。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，
it was a cool little script and I played Sandra Bernhard came out to do it to Australia in the early 90s and I auditioned and got this part. But I had started acting classes like youth at a youth program here in Sydney when I was like eight years old and then a casting agent came to one of my classes and cast me in this movie. So you had this, and you ended up going to, you did this acting class, did you end up going and studying acting as well, like in an academy? I didn't get into NIDA, which is like the sort of, you know,
这是一个很酷的小剧本，我扮演桑德拉·伯恩哈特在90年代初来到澳大利亚拍摄这部电影，我参加了试镜并得到了这个角色。但我很小的时候就在悉尼的一个青年项目开始上表演课，自我大约八岁起，然后有一个选角导演来到我的一个班级，把我选进了这部电影。所以你有了这个，你最后去，你上了这个表演课，你最后也去学习表演了吗，比如在学院里？我没有考上NIDA，也就是那种，你知道的，
most sort of well-known Australian, the National Institute of Dramatic Art, which is, you know, most sort of well-known Australian, the National Institute of Dramatic Art, which has, you know, very famous alumni. But I didn't get in, guys. Didn't get in. Oh, they're all out. So I just... By the way, they're kicking themselves now. And by the way, if you know an Australian, they kick themselves the other way.
最知名的澳大利亚国家戏剧艺术学院，你知道的，那里有很多非常著名的校友。但我没考上，伙计们。没考上。哦，他们现在都后悔了。顺便说一句，他们现在肠子都悔青了。而且顺便说一句，如果你认识一个澳大利亚人，他们会反方向后悔。
Yeah, they kick the other way. It's not a lot of people know that. Not a lot of people know that, they kick the other way. But you know, I've worked with Jason too. I've worked out two out of three of you guys, which is you, I love you, I love you. I've worked with Jason too. I've worked out two out of three of you guys, which is pretty cool. This is where I leave you. Oh, this is where I leave you.
对，他们会反方向后悔。没有多少人知道这一点。没有多少人知道这一点，他们会反方向后悔。但你知道的，我也和杰森合作过。我和你们三个人中的两个合作过，也就是你，我爱你，我爱你。我也和杰森合作过。我和你们三个人中的两个合作过，这挺酷的。这就是我离开你的地方。哦，这就是我离开你的地方。
That's so nice. How long ago was that now? That was the comedy about sitting Shiva. Yes, it's where Jane Fonda. The Sean Levy, via Sean. Sean Levy, the great Sean Levy, Adam Driver, Cory Stoll, Tina Fey. Amazing cast, wasn't it? Yeah, that is amazing cast.
太好了。那已经是多久以前的事了？那是那部关于坐在希瓦（犹太丧俗）上的喜剧。对，詹妮弗·方达也在的那部。肖恩·列维，伟大的肖恩·列维，亚当·德赖弗，科里·斯托尔，蒂娜·菲。令人惊叹的演员阵容，对吧？对，那是一个令人惊叹的演员阵容。
Yeah, we had a great break. So you guys, so, so, but so to go back, so you go back, you get this, you get this movie with Sandra Bernhardt. She flies all the way to Australia. You do this movie, then what happens? You that movie comes out and you're like, I'm sad. What?
是的，我们度过了一段美好的时光。所以你们，所以，所以，但回到正题，所以你回去，你得到了这个，你得到了这部与桑德拉·伯恩哈特的合作。她一路飞到澳大利亚。你拍了这部电影，然后发生了什么？那部电影上映了，你在想，我很难过。什么？
What? Yeah, I'm done. Maybe what's a good old film? Literally just paired at the phone. Ready to roll. Then, no, I like I finished high school and I started auditioning for other TV jobs and stuff in Australia
什么？是的，我完了。也许什么是好老电影？字面意思刚刚看着手机。随时准备出发。然后，不，我喜欢我高中毕业，然后我开始在澳大利亚试镜其他的电视工作什么的，
and I got a few bits and pieces. And then when I was 18, I got cast in this film called Two Hands, opposite Heath Ledger, directed by this wonderful writer, director, Gregor Jordan, and that film was a really big hit in Australia, and that was like, you know, a sort of turning point, I suppose, for me, back home. So that was in like 99, 98 or something. I was like pretty young,
我得到了一些零星的角色。然后在我18岁的时候，我在一部名为《双手》的电影中获得了一个角色，搭档是希斯·莱杰，由这位出色的编剧兼导演格雷戈尔·乔丹执导，那部电影在澳大利亚取得了巨大的成功，这对我来说可以说是回到家乡的一个转折点吧。所以那大概是99年、98年左右。我还挺年轻的，
as I was Heath who was like teenage. So you have this big hit in Australia, like I'm out of here. Then I did the classic thing of going to LA to just try to audition for years, like I'm trying to get an agent. I remember I got my first agent. And I was so excited. I was like, I'm all set. I've got this agent. She's really great. She's got a great client list and she signed me off the movie and went back to Australia. Never heard from her again. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Where's the great Bobby Connovoly this morning? Bobby, he's unpacking. He's because we just got back. So he's like in the trenches with the kids unpacking, but he says hello to all
像希斯还是个十几岁的少年。所以你在澳大利亚取得了巨大的成功，就像我要离开这里。然后我做了经典的举动，去洛杉矶尝试试镜好几年，就像我试图找一个经纪人。我记得我找到了我的第一个经纪人。我当时太兴奋了。我想，我都搞定了。我有了这个经纪人。她真的很棒。她有很多出色的客户名单，她把我签下了电影然后回到了澳大利亚。再也没有她的消息。再也没有。再也没有。再也没有。再也没有。再也没有。再也没有。伟大的鲍比·坎纳瓦尔今天早上在哪里？鲍比，他在收拾行李。因为我们刚回来。所以他就像在前线和孩子们一起收拾行李，但他向你们所有人都问好。
of you. Yes, Bobby Connovoi, who was on Will and Grace forever, playing Will's boyfriend. Yes, yes. And we played, he played my superhero boss, or super villain boss, and the thing with Melissa McCarthy, where I had crab arms. How did you guys meet? Bloody funny. We met through an actor called Tate Donovan, who was on Damages, which is a show, a TV show
是的，鲍比·坎纳瓦尔，他在《威尔和格蕾丝》里演了很久威尔的男友。是的，是的。我们扮演，他扮演我的超级英雄老板，或者是超级反派老板，在那部有梅丽尔·麦卡西的戏里，我在里面有螃蟹手。你们是怎么认识的？该死的有趣。我们通过一个叫泰特·多诺万的演员认识的，他演过《法网裂痕》，那是我和格伦·克洛斯一起拍的一部剧，一部电视剧。
I did with Glenn Close. Yes, you did. For a long time. Yes, and Marty Short was on that. And Glenn Kessler. Yes, yes. And Glenn Kessler and Daniel Zell. And then Zellman was one of the creators.
是的，你演过。演了很长时间。是的，玛蒂·肖特也在那里面。还有格伦·凯斯勒。是的，是的。还有格伦·凯斯勒和丹尼尔·泽尔。然后泽尔曼是创作者之一。
And Dan Hermeson used to be there. Look at all these connections. Look at all the guys. We're just crunching it out. Look at this. Yeah. Now, where are, is Bobby juggling that you have two young boys, right? Yes, and he has a third boy, Jake, who is 28.
丹·赫梅森以前也在那儿。看看所有这些联系。看看这些家伙。我们正在全力以赴。看看这个。是的。现在，鲍比是在兼顾吗，你们有两个年幼的男孩，对吧？是的，他还有一个第三个男孩，杰克，已经28岁了。
Yes. Oh my God. He's got boys, boys, boys. Yeah. Wow. How do you guys do it? You guys both look so much. I mean, I'm sorry if you get this question a lot,
是的。哦，天哪。他有男孩，男孩，男孩。是的。哇。你们是怎么做到的？你们两个看起来都那么年轻。我是说，如果你们经常听到这个问题我很抱歉，
but it is just, I don't know how people do it, where you got two young kids and both parents are working all the time out of town. It must be tough, but are they both now in kindergarten or first grade? Yeah, they're both like sort of, but they've been, it's like, I've had to a job. It's a harder, right?
但这是，我不知道人们是怎么做到的，你有两个年幼的孩子，而且父母双方都在外地全职工作。那一定很艰难，但他们现在都上幼儿园或一年级了吗？对，他们俩都差不多，但他们一直在，就像我不得不兼顾工作一样。这更难，对吧？
It's hard, yeah, because then they're in school school but it's a little bit case by case basis. I don't know about you guys with your families and children and stuff but a little bit case by case just do your best like time. Right. Sometimes the summer they can come but yeah. A little bit and they've gone to schools in LA. I don't know you know so it's like a little bit of that kind of but I guess older is it gets harder.
这很难，是的，因为他们上了真正的学校，但这有点具体情况具体分析。我不知道你们和你们的家庭以及孩子之类的是怎么样的，但有点具体情况具体分析，尽力而为吧。对。有时候夏天他们可以来，但是是的。有一点，而且他们在洛杉矶上过学。我不知道你们懂的，所以有点那种，但我猜随着年龄增长，事情会变得更难。
Pardon me as they get older, right? Well, it does get harder. It does get harder and it's a lot more of a negotiation and because what happens is they have friends. Jason knows this too. They have friends and they're like, you're like, hey, we're gonna do this thing. They're like, no, man, I wanna be with my buddies.
原谅我，随着他们长大，对吧？嗯，确实变得更难了。确实更难了，而且需要更多的协商，因为情况是这样的，他们有朋友。杰森也懂这个。他们有朋友，他们会觉得，你会说，嘿，我们要去做这件事。他们会说，不，老兄，我想和我的死党在一起。
Right. And we don't care about your thing. Yeah, craft service is great, but. I know. That's such a joy card, they talk about that they just go I was I Going through a thing right now where my 14 year old is on a trip and I haven't talked to him for three and a half days now because He's his phone and
对。而且我们才不在乎你的事呢。是的，演员工资和餐饮服务很棒，但。我知道。这真是一张让人高兴的牌，他们谈论那些，他们只是说，我正在经历一件事，我14岁的孩子去旅行了，我已经三天半没跟他说话了，因为他的手机和
I am suffering Yeah, I bet he's having a great time and I am going crazy. Yeah, will you have no idea, you have no way to check in with him? Yeah? No, like a chap around. When he got there, when he got there, he was able to check in and he faced time,
我正在受煎熬。是的，我打赌他玩得很开心，而我快疯了。是的，你完全不知道，你没有办法联系他？对吗？没有，就像周围有领队。他到那里的时候，他能够联系我们，他进行了FaceTime，
I faced him and he was great. And then he checked in again later, he was like, hey, we gotta give up our phones now because the deal was on this trip that everybody gives up their phones and that these, these guys, these sort of counselor guys take them. And so we're like, yeah, this is really good. Meanwhile, we're, you know, my ex and I were like, this is great. This is great for him. And now a three days in, she and I were texting each other and he's like, how do we, What about the chaperone? Can you text chaperone? I mean, we can.
我跟他的FaceTime通话了，他状态很好。然后他后来又联系了我们，他说，嘿，我们现在得交出手机了，因为这次旅行的规定是每个人都要交出手机，然后这些，这些家伙，这些领队家伙会把它们收走。所以我们就像，是的，这真的很好。与此同时，我们，你知道的，我和我的前妻就像，这对他太好了。现在已经三天了，我和她在互发短信，然后他就在想，我们怎么做？领队怎么样？你可以给领队发短信吗？我是说，我们可以。
We know that he's, we know he's okay. We've gotten word and stuff. He's fine. And right before he gave up his phone later of the first day, I tried to, I tried to cram another FaceTime in. Less. And he was like, Dad, I can't pick up the phone.
我们知道他，我们知道他没事。我们已经收到消息之类的了。他很好。就在他交出手机之前，第一天的晚些时候，我试图，我试图再进行一次FaceTime通话。更少。而他说，爸爸，我不能接电话。
What are you doing? No, I'm sorry. Yeah, yeah. Just making sure. Oh, I know. I know. I know that's it. A little you doing? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Just want to, I know. Just making sure. I know. I know. I know. That's a little Archie. Oh, people. Guys, Will's sweet. I know he doesn't seem sweet, but this guy got a real soft chewy center.
你在干什么？不，我很抱歉。是的，是的。只是确认一下。哦，我知道。我知道。我知道就是这样。你最近在忙什么？抱歉。是的。是的。只是想，我知道。只是确认一下。我知道。我知道。我知道。那是小阿奇。哦，大家。伙计们，威尔很温柔。我知道他看起来不温柔这家伙其实内心非常柔软。
You're all sweet. My Rose, what's going on this summer? Um, do you have any time to take, uh, any family trips aside from Australia? Well, this was a pretty big one. It was like a month. Um, I was in the Outback. Will, I thought of you. You were. pretty big one. It was like a month. I was in the outback. Well, I thought of you. You were.
你们都很温柔。我的萝丝，这个夏天过得怎么样？嗯，除了澳大利亚，你还有时间进行任何家庭旅行吗？嗯，这次算是一个相当大的旅行。大约有一个月。嗯，我在内陆地区。威尔，我想到了你。你当时。相当大的旅行。大约有一个月。我在内陆地区。威尔，我想到了你。你当时。
Yeah, we went to... We went to... We went to... Laru. We went to Uluru, which is the gorgeous, I mean, incredible, very sacred spiritual site out in the middle of... Middle of Australia, it's wild. If you ever get a chance to go, any of you, please, please,
是的，我们去了……我们去了……我们去了……乌鲁鲁。我们去了乌鲁鲁，那里风景秀丽，我的意思是，令人难以置信，是一个非常神圣的精神圣地，位于……澳大利亚中部，太疯狂了。如果你有机会去的话，你们任何人，请，请，
to go. So, so funny, it's been Rosenai did this thing. We actually had this friend of hers who directed it, did all this, shut all this incredible footage all over Australia. And so, and then we kind of narrated our way as we, as our characters went through with this great footage.
去看看。太搞笑了，我和萝丝做过一件事。我们其实有她的一位朋友导演了这件事，在澳大利亚各地拍摄了所有这些令人难以置信的画面。然后，当我们的角色带着这些精彩的画面穿行时，我们就顺便做了解说。
So, I, it feels like Rosenai have been on a tour of Australia together. So that's why she's like, we were in, and I was like, we were about to arrive. I don't know what we went there. But I remember. Do you, I, I, I've dumbed up questions.
所以，我觉得萝丝和我一起进行了一次澳大利亚之旅。这就是为什么她会说，我们当时在，而我当时想，我们正要到达。我不知道我们为什么去那儿。但我记得。你，我，我，我问了一些愚蠢的问题。
Do you miss it when, when you're not there? Like just a family, just a bit of that. Oh, I do, have you ever been? I've never been, I wanna go. Have you ever been a drag to you? I've never been a drag to you. I've never been a drag to you. I've never been, it's a very long flight. Have you, Jason? I've never been, I want to go. Oh Sean, you've never been this way. I've never been, it's a very long flight.
当你不在那里的时候，你会想念它吗？就像家庭生活那样，有一点点。哦，我确实想念，你曾经去过吗？我从来没去过，我想去。你曾经去过澳大利亚吗？我从来没去过澳大利亚。我从来没去过澳大利亚。我从来没去过，那是一场非常漫长的飞行。你去过吗，杰森？我从来没去过，我想去。哦，肖恩，你从来没去过那边。我从来没去过，那是一场非常漫长的飞行。
Have you, Jason? I have a bunch of times, yeah, I love it. I love it. I love it. I would love to go there. I will say though, and this might be controversial. When you fly that long, you would love for it to be... You would like the distance, you would like the difference of the locale
你去过吗，杰森？我去过很多次，是的，我非常喜欢。我太喜欢了。我很想去那里。不过我要说的是，这可能会有争议。当你飞了那么长时间，你希望……你会希望目的地的不同程度
to be equal to the distance of the flight. You know what I mean? In other words, it's very similar to the U.S. in that people speak English and they look sort of anglo and they're all kind of, except they drive in this. It's a little bit like Canada, to me, which is great. I love Canada, but I can get there in an hour. You know, just like go north into Vancouver. I feel you were under the well. I'm getting a feeling that you are underwhelmed. No, but I guess in fairness, I was in Melbourne and in Sydney a lot, but I haven't been to the
能够对等飞行的距离。你知道我的意思吗？换句话说，这和美国非常相似，因为人们说英语，他们看起来有点像盎格鲁人，而且他们都挺……除了他们靠左驾驶。这对我来说有点像加拿大，这很棒。我喜欢加拿大，但我一个小时就能到那儿。你知道的，只要向北进入温哥华就行。我感觉你有点兴致缺缺。我有一种感觉，你觉得有点名不副实。不，但公平起-来讲，我经常去墨尔本和悉尼，但我没去过
outback. I haven't been up in Brisbane. I haven't been to surface paradise. Yeah, you're in the city and that makes sense. And I feel like this is the problem that we have in the world in general, which is all the cities have become so it's the same stores in every city, right? Like you can go, yeah, you can go to Paris or you can go to Tokyo or you can go to London or you can go to St. Louis and there's a, a Fendi store.
内陆地区。我没去过布里斯班。我没去过冲浪者天堂。是的，你在城市里，这很合情合理。我觉得这也是我们整个世界所面临的问题，那就是所有的城市都变得如此……每个城市的商店都一样，对吧？就像你可以去，是的，你可以去巴黎，或者你可以去东京，或者你可以去伦敦，或者你可以去圣路易斯，那里都有Fendi专卖店。
Yeah, and Sean, good news. There's a theory there and a commercial. Oh fantastic. I'm in. I don't mind the flight. There's a big. So wait Rose, you can get into a Vince. Go ahead, Sean.
是的，而且肖恩，有好消息。那里有一个理论和一个广告。哦，太棒了。算我一个。我不介意飞行。有一个大消息。所以等等，萝丝，你可以进一家芬迪。继续吧，肖恩。
I was able to sing a Vince in Australia. And that's a stretch. We'll be right back. As far as the sponsor by BetterHelp, so with just a short amount of time left to go on the Broadway with my show, you know, everybody always asks me, where do you live? I say the theater, because I go from my apartment to the theater and the apartment to the theater back and forth.
我在澳大利亚能去芬迪逛逛。这有点牵强。我们马上回来。本期节目由BetterHelp赞助，随着我在百老汇的演出只剩下很短的时间，你知道，每个人总是问我，你住在哪里？我说剧院，因为我从公寓到剧院，从公寓到剧院来回跑。
I don't really, really have too much of a life outside of what I'm doing right now. And so you start to feel stuck, you start to get stuck crazy in both my tiny apartment and the tiny backstage of the theater. And so, you know, it can drive you a little mad even though you're doing what you love doing. You kind of have to figure out how to cope with that. And you might need some help, right? And so sometimes we're faced with issues like this where we we're feeling stuck or feeling like cabin fever, you're feeling just the anxiety from being confined, right? So maybe it's not that and you're thinking about a
除了我目前正在做的事情之外，我真的没有太多自己的生活。所以你开始感到被困住，你在我狭小的公寓和剧院狭小的后台里开始感到快要疯了。所以，你知道的，这会让你有点抓狂，尽管你正在做着你热爱的事情。你不得不找出如何应对这种情况的方法。你可能需要一些帮助，对吧？所以有时我们会面临这样的问题，我们感到被困住，或者有幽闭恐惧症，你只觉得被禁锢带来的焦虑，对吧？所以也许不是这个，你在考虑
career change or feeling like your relationship needs some TLC, whatever it is, therapy can help you map out your future and trust yourself to find the way forward and it can even help you out of sticky situations like feeling like you're trapped, right? And so I talked to my therapist about the mental toll that it takes on to do five months of a show, and it's hard, it's joyful, but it's also mentally taxing.
改变职业或者觉得你的关系需要一些关爱，无论是什么，治疗都可以帮你规划未来，并相信自己能找到前进的方向，它甚至能帮你摆脱像觉得自己被困住这样的棘手情况，对吧？所以我和我的治疗师谈论了进行五个月的演出所带来的心理负担，这很艰难，令人愉快，但也让人精神疲惫。
So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with BetterHelp.
所以如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上，旨在提供便利、灵活且适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。让治疗成为你的地图，选择BetterHelp。
Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month that's betterhelpagelp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Viori clothing. Guys, you know I don't like to talk about my personal life. I try to keep my life as private as possible. But Scottie took me on a helicopter ride recently. And it was amazing.
今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartless，首月即可享受九折优惠，网址是betterhelpagelp.com斜杠smartless。Smartless获得Viori服装的支持。伙计们，你们知道我不喜欢谈论我的个人生活。我尽量让我的生活尽可能保持隐私。但斯科蒂最近带我坐了一次直升机。太棒了。
It was incredible. We toured like the whole city and we got real close to the Statue of Liberty. I've never been that close to the Statue of Liberty. Wow, deja vu. Anyway, tired of sacrificing style for comfort or get this vice versa, look no further than Viori.
简直难以置信。我们游览了整个城市，离自由女神像非常近。我从未离自由女神像那么近过。哇，似曾相识的感觉。不管怎样，你是否厌倦了为了舒适而牺牲时尚，或者反过来，来看看Viori吧。
The performance clothing brand that combines both, Viori, offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet, making it the perfect investment in your happiness. From joggers to leggings to crew necks, Viori has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish, no matter what you're doing. So, back to the helicopter ride. It's running around, running around. Like, what do I wear for helicopter ride? Every single time I go on a helicopter ride, I go, running around. Like, what do I wear for a helicopter ride?
这个高性能服装品牌兼顾了两者，Viori提供地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装，使其成为对你幸福感的完美投资。从慢跑裤到打底裤再到圆领衫，Viori拥有你保持舒适和时尚所需的一切，无论你在做什么。所以，回到直升机之旅。到处跑，到处跑。就像，我坐直升机该穿什么？每次我坐直升机，我都会想，到处跑。就像，我坐直升机该穿什么？
Every single time I go on a helicopter ride, I go in Viori. But next time, I'll know to bring an extra pair. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's VU-ORI.com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase,
每次我坐直升机，我都穿着Viori。但下次我知道要带多一套了。对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买八折优惠。在Viori.com斜杠smartless购买地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装。网址是VU-ORI.com斜杠smartless。你不仅可以享受首次购买八折优惠，
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over 75 bucks and free returns. Go to VURI.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of VURI clothing. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, our thanks to Zippercruder for their support. If you're hiring, you know that it's incredibly hard
还可以享受任何超过75美元的美国订单免运费和免费退货。前往VURI.com斜杠smartless，探索VURI服装的多功能性。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，感谢ZipRecruiter的支持。如果你正在招聘，你就会知道吸引顶尖人才
to attract top talent. And with the current labor market conditions, it's even harder than ever. That's why you want a partner who gets it. Zipp Recruder. Zippercruder knows how tough it is right now, but they've figured out solutions for the problems you are facing.
是极其困难的。在当前的劳动力市场条件下，这比以往任何时候都更加困难。这就是为什么你需要一个懂得这一切的合作伙伴。ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter深知现在的艰难，但他们已经为你面临的问题找到了解决方案。
See for yourself, right now you can try them for free at zippercruder.com-smartless. Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To reach more of the right people, Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To reach more of the right people, Zippercruder posts your job to 100 plus job sites. Need to hire ASAP? Zippercruder smart technology finds great matches for your job sooner.
亲自来看看吧，现在你可以在zippercruder.com-smartless上免费试用他们。ZipRecruiter已准备好应对你的招聘挑战。为了接触到更多合适的人，ZipRecruiter已准备好应对你的招聘挑战。为了接触到更多合适的人，ZipRecruiter将你的职位发布到100多个求职网站上。需要尽快招人？ZipRecruiter的智能技术能更快地为你的职位找到绝佳匹配。
Want first dibs on talent? Zippercruder lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job. Plus, Zippercruder's pricing is straightforward. No surprise costs. Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need, Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder's pricing is straightforward, no surprise costs. Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need, Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first day.
想要优先挑选人才？ZipRecruiter让你能够邀请最合格的人来申请你的职位。此外，ZipRecruiter的定价非常明确。没有隐藏费用。与一个真正了解你需求的招聘合作伙伴携手，ZipRecruiter。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的五分之四的雇主，定价明确，没有隐藏费用。与一个真正了解你需求的招聘合作伙伴携手，ZipRecruiter。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的五分之四的雇主在第一天内就能获得优质候选人。
Just go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercruder for free, zippercruder.com-slash-smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com-slash-smartless. S-M-A-R-T-L-E-D-L-S. Zipperckutter, the smartest way to hire. All right, back to the show. But Rose, like, when you go there and come back, what is the culture shock? When you first move, like, what is the difference between... I mean... We'll still go it on the bits. What is the thing that you noticed the most...
只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用ZipRecruiter，zippercruder.com-slash-smartless。再重复一遍，那是zippercruder.com-slash-smartless。S-M-A-R-T-L-E-D-L-S。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。好了，回到节目中。但是萝丝，比如，当你去那儿又回来时，文化冲击是什么？当你第一次搬过去时，比如，两者的区别是什么……我是说……我们还是继续讲段子吧。你注意到的最多的是什么……
What are the differences you noticed the most? About Australia and the US? Well, Australia is a little more laid back, I think. In general, the people are probably a little bit more laid back. And it's just a bigger... This place is just... You can't compete with the scale and the amount of people and things like Australia feels... it's just a smaller population it's like and they're called harder
你注意到的最大区别是什么？关于澳大利亚和美国？嗯，我觉得澳大利亚更悠闲一些。总的来说，那里的民风可能更随性一点。而且那是一个更大的……这个地方只是……你无法与澳大利亚的规模、人口数量和事物相比，澳大利亚给人的感觉……它只是一个更小的人口，就像而且他们被称为更努力
and it's it's just it looks hot yeah it's not but only during our winter only during our winter it can be but you also like the people like they're just in that same sort of way that that the English have the same sort of thing and I think Canadians have this little bit as well maybe a common well thing there's just people have a better sense of taking the piss out of each other and themselves. They don't take themselves as seriously as Americans do. Yeah. That's on the whole. I know that that's a very sweeping generalization. So again, hold back your fucking letters. But I think I think that there is that thing about you don't take yourself to seriously. And that's fun.
而且它，它看起来很热，是的，不是，但只有在我们的冬天，只有在我们的冬天，它可能是这样的，但你也喜欢那些人，就像他们只是以那种方式，英国人也有类似的方式，我想加拿大人也有一点这种特质，也许是英联邦的东西，人们有一种更好的自嘲和开玩笑的精神。他们不像美国人那样把自己看得那么严肃。是的。总的来说是这样。我知道这是一个非常以偏概全的概括。所以再次声明，请收回你们那些该死的信件。但我认为，我认为确实存在这样一种特质，即你不会把自己看得太严肃。这很有趣。
There's a kind of, it's very fun. All the people I know in Australia, I guess a lot of them are sort of actors and comedians and etc. But there is that kind of fun vibe. Do you feel like they're more a united country than we are? Ooh, it's a good question. I'll look, it's definitely, how do you feel? I don't get real with her, dude.
有一种，非常有趣。我在澳大利亚认识的所有人，我猜他们很多都是演员和喜剧演员之类的。但确实有一种那种有趣的氛围。你觉得他们比我们更像一个团结的国家吗？哦，这是一个好问题。我，听着，这绝对是，你怎么看？别跟她太较真了，伙计。
I was curious about that. Because it's smaller and you're, everything you're saying will, I just thought like. I was gonna say though, it sounds like there's a lot more common sense sort of policies in way of living there than perhaps there we get into here just because of the opposite sides of things. Is it very separated here at least right now?
我对那个挺好奇的。因为面积更小，而且你，你说的每一句话，威尔，我只是觉得……不过我想说的是，听起来那里在生活方式上似乎有很多更符合常识的政策，也许比我们在这里遇到的要多，仅仅因为各方立场的不同。这里的意见分歧很大，至少目前是这样？
Yeah, I think the vision here at the moment is pretty extraordinary and pretty like it's not as it's not as extreme. Australians are used to government in their life a lot more than Americans are. So for instance, you'll have a speed limit everyone took the vaccine without any, you know, things like that. There's just more use to that involvement. You know, healthcare is free. Although it's just a thing. So it's like it's just a very different mentality
是的，我认为这里的意见分歧目前相当惊人，而且相当……它不像，它没有那么极端。澳大利亚人比美国人更能习惯政府介入他们的生活。所以，举个例子，你会有速度限制，每个人都毫不犹豫地接种了疫苗，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。他们只是更习惯这种干预。你知道的，医疗是免费的。尽管这只是一回事。所以这就像是一种非常不同的心态
of government in your life. Very similar to Canada. Very similar. By the way, I saw you and you can't take it with you. Oh, you did. You were fantastic. Yeah, I love that show. It was my first show I ever did in high school.
关于政府在你的生活中的角色。非常类似于加拿大。非常相似。顺便说一句，我看了你演的《不能带走》。哦，你看过。你演得太棒了。是的，我很喜欢那个节目。那是我在高中时演的第一个节目。
Oh, really? That's what everybody was saying to me. They my first show I ever did in high school. Oh really? That's what everybody was saying to me. They're like I did this in high school. It was like yeah, but but to see to see a Professionally done like that it was fantastic James Earl Jones like Well, you I was gonna this what I was gonna. I was gonna. You've done a lot of theater in fact and you didn't you and Bobby did Medea band I Claim and and do you Do you have any great theaters to our sorry Sean? I'm sure you've claimed. And, and do you, do you have any great theaters to our,
哦，真的吗？这就是每个人都在对我说的话。他们我演的第一个节目是在高中。哦，真的吗？这就是每个人都在对我说的话。他们就像我在高中时演过这个。就好像，是的，但是，但是看到专业人士像那样把它演出来，真是太棒了。詹姆斯·厄尔·琼斯就像，好吧，你，我正要，这就是我要说的。我正要说。事实上你演过很多戏剧，而且你和鲍比不是演过美狄亚……我宣称，而且你，你有什么伟大的戏剧作品要，抱歉肖恩，我抢了你的台词。宣称，而且你，你有什么伟大的戏剧作品要，
sorry Sean, I'm stealing your theater? Yes, yes. What went, yeah, I want to know what went wrong and you can't take it with you. We want to save Faber and Color for Sean. Go ahead, Rose. And I'll see your Faber color. My favorite, that's what my six year old
抱歉肖恩，我抢了你的戏剧话题？是的，是的。什么，是的，我想知道你在《不能带走》里出了什么问题。我们要把“法伯和色彩”留给肖恩。继续吧，萝丝。我要看你的法伯色彩。我的最爱，那就是我的六岁孩子
asks me, look, my five years old. Welcome to Faber, that's a bit right. Yeah. God, any theater stories. I mean, I've had that person have a heart attack in row three. You know, and this is very, very paramedic. This is an Australian, I was doing a plan that to come in. And we were still doing the scene.
问我的，看，我的五岁孩子。欢迎来到法伯，这算是一个梗吧。对。天哪，有什么剧院的故事。我是说，我遇到过有观众在第三排心脏病发作的情况。你知道的，而且这非常非常紧急。这是一个澳大利亚人，我当时正在演一出准备登场的戏。我们当时还在演那场戏。
It was three sisters, the check-off play. And then somebody of a sudden the person just starts going, like that, just bumps over and the party. And did you have to go? We kept going. It was really weird. Yeah, I was going to say, did you have to go? We kept going. It was really weird. Yeah, I was gonna say, do you finish the show? We finished, not only do we finish the show,
那是三姐妹，是那种签到退场的桥段。然后突然间那个人就开始那样，整个人撞倒了，派对就。你当时必须去吗？我们继续演。真的很诡异。对，我本想说，你必须去吗？我们继续演。真的很诡异。对，我本想说，你把演出演完了吗？我们演完了，不仅演完了，
but we didn't stop. We keep going. Stop the scene. So Australia, they're like, unless you've bitten by a snake, you just keep going, right? It's the snake that stops things in Australia. Not the hardest, the most powerful.
而且我们没有停。我们继续演。停掉这场戏。所以澳洲人，他们的态度是，除非你被毒蛇咬了，否则你得继续，对吧？在澳洲，只有蛇能让事情停下来。不是最猛的，也不是最厉害的。
But did you keep going with the flag? We kept going. We kept going. And this poor old gentleman, I think, yeah, they came in and they took him out and everybody stood up and they put him on the stretcher and took him out. Sure. Did they check him for an overdose of a vagimite? Because I know that it's that that can be sometimes high sodium content. Do people still say fair income?
但你们拿着旗子继续演了吗？我们继续演。我们继续演。我想，这位可怜的老绅士，他们进来了，把他抬了出去，所有人都站起来，把他放到担架上抬了出去。当然。他们有没有检查他是否摄入了过量的Vegemite（咸味酵母酱）？因为我知道那个东西有时钠含量很高。大家现在还说 "fair dinkum" 吗？
I mean, I don't think so. I mean, I'm sure they do. It used to be a big one, right? Yeah, it's a little bit dated, this slang, a little bit. What does it mean? Fair dinkam means like really or is that right? Isn't that a replacement for that? Remember Rose, when we did that thing, we did that Q&A and they asked me some Australian,
我是说，我觉得没有吧。我是说，我确信还是有人说的。这以前是个很常用的词，对吧？对，这个俚语稍微有点过时了，有那么一点。它是什么意思？"Fair dinkum" 的意思是像 "真的" 或是 "对吧"？这不是那个词的替代词吗？露丝，还记得吗，当我们做那件事的时候，我们做了一个问答，他们问了我一些澳大利亚的，
they asked me fair dinkam. And I said that that's Faradinkum is a term that's used to describe like somebody who's okay to hook up with. It's a Faradinkum. Yeah. Yeah. That wasn't that bad, but I like it.
他们问我 "fair dinkum"。我说 "fair dinkum" 是用来形容那种可以约会的人的词。是个 "fair dinkum"。对。对。那倒没那么糟，不过我喜欢。
I thought Faradinkum was like... Early 80s. Yeah, like more like, oh, do you... Yeah, it's a little 80s, probably. A little bit, it's a little bit dated, fancy couple. I got a rose, I got a good one for you. Yeah. I think I told these guys, what do you call chickens?
我以为 "fair dinkum" 就像是……80年代初。对，更像是，哦，你……对，稍微有点80年代的感觉吧。有那么一点，稍微有点过时了，"fair dinkum"。露丝，我这有个好笑的。对。我想我告诉过这几位了，你叫鸡什么来着？
Who's, what do you call a chicken staring at lettuce? What? Chicken sees a salad. I've been using that the last 48 hours and getting a lot of folks. Rose, Jesus, I'm sure. Will, do you have any dad jokes? I don't have any dad jokes, not right now.
谁，你管盯着生菜看的鸡叫什么？什么？鸡看到沙拉。我过去48小时一直在用这个梗，把好多人都逗乐了。露丝，天哪，我敢肯定。威尔，你有什么冷笑话吗？我没有什么冷笑话，现在没有。
I'll have more by the end. Minor more just in the moment, like just. But here's how great Sean is. Sean just FaceTime me in the middle of the day or night, the other day I couldn't tell. And I was like, okay, I'll pick up the FaceTime. I'll pick up the FaceTime. And he said, he's picking up, hello. Hey, so just real quick, just for a quick, quick joke.
到最后我会有更多。我的大多是即兴的，就那种。不过肖恩厉害就厉害在这里。肖恩前几天在大白天还是大晚上给我打FaceTime，我都分不清。然后我想，好吧，我接听FaceTime。我接听FaceTime。然后他说，他接通了，喂。嘿，就一会会儿，就讲个极其短暂的笑话。
And then he tells me that joke and I laugh and he hangs out. That's right, that's the kind of socializing I enjoy. That's it. A little hit and run. And that's exactly right. I know you. I know you're so good. We came up the other day with, I was told Sean this, that thing. A little hit and run. And that's exactly right. I know you. I know you.
然后他给我讲了那个笑话，我笑了，他就挂了。没毛病，这正是我喜欢的社交方式。就是这样。快闪快回。完全正确。我懂你。我知道你太棒了。我们前几天想出了，我告诉肖恩这个，那个。快闪快回。完全正确。我懂你。我知道你。
I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you.
我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。
我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。
I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know that. Nice little visit from the youth fairy. I like that. But here's the thing, Rose, what do you use on your skin because you look like you're 12 years old? Oh my.
我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我懂你。我知道了。青春仙子来串门，感觉真不错。我喜欢这个。不过话说回来，露丝，你在皮肤上用什么保养品，因为你看起来就像12岁一样？哦，天哪。
Your skin is flawless. Wow. Oh my gosh. You look great. Yeah, congratulations. Congratulations. What do you do? What do you do?
你的皮肤太无瑕了。哇。哦，天哪。你状态真好。对，恭喜。恭喜。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么做到的？
I think it's all. Do you do all the scrubs and the peels and the thing and the thing? I think it's the lighting in here. I'm not trying to be. I think it's all lighting. He wants another name for your turn. You go to sleep early, you eat right, you kind of do all that stuff. All those boring things I guess, but it is very dark in here. It is dark.
我想这全是。你做了所有的去角质、换肤、那个还有那个吗？我想这全是因为这里的灯光。我不是故意要。我觉得全是灯光。他想给你的诀窍换个名字。你睡得早，吃得健康，你基本上把那些事都做了。我想都是那些无聊的事，不过这里确实很黑。这里是挺黑的。
It's got a soft light. It's a really soft light. What do you, what do you pick out on? What do you just love to pick out on through? Look at this. Say something, she's having a big soft, they're both having Coca-Cola's. But this is because I've got food poisoning on the plane. On the one back.
这里有柔和的光。这光真的很柔和。你，你最喜欢吃什么？你最喜欢挑什么来吃？看这个。说点什么吧，她有个很大的柔和，他们俩都在喝可口可乐。但这是因为我在飞机上食物中毒了。回程的飞机上。
No. And nothing of Coca-Cola can't solve. Phil P, so I got the blood dog. Don't name the airline. I know, I know. I didn't, I was. Did you guys go through, did you stop? I don't know the airline. I know. I didn't. Did you guys go through?
没有。没有什么事是一罐可口可乐解决不了的。菲尔·P，所以我得了血便。别说出航空公司。我知道，我知道。我没说，我。你们经历过，你们停下来了吗？我不知道那家航空公司。我知道。我没说。你们经历过吗？
Did you stop? We just stopped in LA. We changed planes and then on the way from New York to JFK. Just recently just yesterday. Yesterday I got in last night, but I was like throwing up the whole time. Last night? Oh, how do you live here doing this? Oh, no, I feel okay.
你们中途停留了吗？我们只是在洛杉矶停留。我们转机了，然后从纽约去肯尼迪机场。就在最近，就在昨天。我昨晚刚到，但我一直在吐，从头吐到尾。昨晚？哦，你这样怎么生活？哦，不，我感觉还好。
Yeah, I feel okay. Yeah, I feel okay. But it was so gross. Like the tiny bag of the plane. Oh, I feel okay, yeah, I feel okay, yeah, I feel okay, but it was so gross like the tiny bag of the plane. Oh, I don't know. I know. I know. So gross.
对，我感觉还好。对，我感觉还好。但太恶心了。就像飞机上那个小袋子。哦，我感觉还好，对，我感觉还好，对，我感觉还好，但太恶心了，就像飞机上那个小袋子。哦，我不知道。我知道。我知道。太恶心了。
Food poisoning is the worst. Food poisoning takes over your whole brain. It's amazing. Yeah, it's like quite, it's like your whole whole. And you guys had the kids with you as well as you and Bobby and the kids. They were asleep though because it was the last leg of the flight. So it was okay. I've just never had it on a plane, but it was like, how much longer have you got left, showing off the show?
食物中毒是最糟糕的。食物中毒会接管你的整个大脑。这太神奇了。对，简直就像，就像你的整个整个。而且你们带了孩子，你、博比还有孩子们都在。不过他们睡着了，因为那是飞行的最后一段。所以还好。我只是从来没有在飞机上遇到过，当时的想法是，肖恩，你离演出结束还有多久？
How long has it been? Um, August 27th is our last day. Oh, wow, okay. Yeah, August 27th is the closing night. Um. How do you guys know each other? Like, how do you all know? It's 23, 23 years ago.
已经演了多久了？嗯，8月27日是我们的最后一天。哦，哇，好吧。对，8月27日是闭幕之夜。嗯。你们是怎么认识的？你们是怎么认识的？那是23、23年前了。
I was his acting teacher. Wait, how, no, I, no. Yeah, I, and I still got acting teacher. Wait, how? No, I. Yeah, I still go to him. I'm still working on it. No, we used to play poker. I met, I met will actually before the poker thing, but we weren't, we didn't get close until we all started playing poker, like regularly every week. And then with Jason and with everybody and with blah, blah, blah.
我是他的表演老师。等等，怎么，不，我。对，我，我还是表演老师。等等，怎么？不，我。对，我还是去找他。我还在琢磨这事。不对，我们以前一起打扑克。其实在打扑克之前我就认识，我就认识威尔了，但我们并不是很熟，直到我们开始定期一起打扑克，差不多每周一次。然后跟杰森还有大家，还有blablabla。
And then yeah, we were just years and years ago. Years and years. And in that time, we've done two shows together. Shall we never even talk about? We were just And then yeah, we were just years and years and years. And in that time, we've done two shows together. Sean, we never even talked about we've done two shows together. What is it? We did up all night on NBC with Christina, Applegate and Maya.
然后，对，那是很多很多年前了。很多很多年。在那期间，我们一起合作过两部剧。肖恩，我们甚至从没聊过这个。然后，对，那是很多很多很多年前了。在那期间，我们一起合作过两部剧。肖恩，我们甚至从没聊过我们一起合作过两部剧。是什么来着？我们在NBC和克里斯蒂娜·艾普加特还有玛娅一起演过《备受关注》。
And then we did the Miller's on CBS. Cool. We'd gone on the memory. Sean, we went on that trip and Sean called like a week later, calling back. He's like, I think I'm going to do the show with you next year. And I was like, Oh, yeah. Isn't that? Wow. Sean, did I see that you've got a compression sleeve on your right arm? I'm both. Yeah. Oh, from playing piano. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. No, I'm on the lifting weights. Yeah, exactly. Did you lift up a heavy exiled the other day? Did you, but it's not how the wrists, your wrists, some.
然后我们在CBS演过《米勒一家》。酷。我们去过那趟旅行，然后肖恩大约一周后打电话回来说。他说，我明年好像要跟你一起拍个剧。然后我说，哦，是吗。不是吗？哇。肖恩，我看到你右胳膊上戴着压力袖套了吗？两边都戴了。对。哦，因为弹钢琴。对。对。哇。不，我是因为举重。对，没错。你前几天举了什么沉重的重物吗？你举了，但不是手腕的问题，你的手腕，有些。
The wrists are a decent, they're decent. The short, I should hands at the end of every show. I used them before and then twice after every day. Did you, so are you a piano prodigy? Like from a... Sure. No, I started playing when I was five and then I thought I was going to be a conductor and composed music and be a concert pianist.
手腕还行，还算凑合。短的，我每场演出结束时都要用到手。演出前用一次，每天演出后用两次。那你是个钢琴神童吗？是从……当然。不，我五岁开始弹，然后我以为我会成为一名指挥家和音乐作曲家，成为一名音乐会钢琴家。
And then I got the acting bug early on. And then I became a music director out of college. And that's what you gave you the food poisoning, right? The acting bug? Yeah. No. Speaking of, I say fans, I took my first cold plunge, the other day rose, have you ever been doing your whole body?
然后我早早就迷上了表演。大学毕业后我成了一名音乐总监。这就是让你食物中毒的原因，对吧？表演迷？对。没有。说到这个，粉丝们，我前几天进行了我的第一次冷水浸泡，露丝，你做过全身的吗？
I mean, so intimate. I'm so into it. Oh my God. I'm like, I never get into that stuff and I'm addicted to it. Rose, tell me about the first time. Tell me about the first time because what does that feel like? It's really? I want to, yeah, I mean, I don't know how you, I'm very... I didn't like it. Yeah. I didn't like it. So, do I end up liking it after two or three or four times? You kind of get addicted to it. I got it. I'm addicted like it. I didn't like it. So do I end up liking it after two or three or four times?
我是说，太深入了。我太沉迷了。哦，天哪。我这人从不搞那些东西，但我对它上瘾了。露丝，跟我讲讲第一次的经历。跟我讲讲第一次的经历，因为那是什么感觉？真的吗？我想，对，我是说，我不知道你是怎么，我非常……我不喜欢。对。我不喜欢。那我经历两三次或四次之后会开始喜欢它吗？你有点对它上瘾了。我懂了。我上瘾了，我喜欢它。我不喜欢。那我经历两三次或四次之后会开始喜欢它吗？
You kind of get addicted to it. I got it. I'm addicted to it. It's like you just because it's becomes like something you have to overcome and the the the the high afterward is just you and it's not even high You just feel really you just you relax you sleep really well I found really helps you me fall asleep and your skin looks amazing. Like it does something amazing. Thank you. That's what it was. So, but I built my first, I can't believe you guys,
你有点对它上瘾了。我懂了。我上瘾了。就像你，因为这变成了一件你必须克服的事情，而且之后的那个兴奋感，只有你，甚至都不是兴奋感，你只是感到真正的，你只是放松了，你睡得非常好。我发现它真的对我有帮助，能让我入睡，而且你的皮肤看起来棒极了。就像它有某种神奇的功效。谢谢。原来是这样。所以，不过我建了第一个，我真不敢相信你们，
you know that I built my first coat punch 10 years ago before anybody else did. I'm now building my third one out here. And I swear to God, and you just go away. So hang on a sec. When you say you built it, you're slapping together all the ceramic
你们知道我在10年前别人之前就建了第一个冷水浴池吗？我现在正在这里建第三个。我向上帝发誓，你只要走开。等等。当你说你建的时候，你是在把所有的陶瓷拼在一起
on the tub there and running. No, no, no, no, no, running. I'm doing a lot of like, I should go there. Hey, keep working while you guys sitting around like. I'm gonna be a bit of a, wait, wait, I want to get out. I want to ask Rose, when you first put, because I kind of want to try it, because I do my arms every day. Yeah, yeah. But I want to, when you first put your toe in, I feel like it would be,
弄那个浴缸，然后通水。不，不，不，不，不，通水。我做了很多类似，我应该去那里的。嘿，你们坐在这儿闲晃，快去干活吧。我得，等等，等等，我想出来。我想问问露丝，你第一次把，因为我也挺想试试的，因为我每天都锻炼手臂。对，对。但我想，当你第一次把脚趾放进去时，我觉得那会是，
I might buy it would be so sensitive. I'd be like, I'm out. I can't do the whole, if you start with sauna, right? If you start, you're really hot. And then you get in it. Yeah. But I'm from Australia. So we swim in the ocean in the winter.
我会觉得太敏感了。我会想，我撤了。我可受不了全部，如果你先蒸桑拿，对吧？如果你先蒸，你觉得非常热。然后你再进去。对。但我来自澳大利亚。所以我们在冬天的海里游泳。
So we went to back home now, right? And I was still swimming every day in the ocean. And the water is freezing. And so cold. Yeah. Pretty cold, but I go straight in. And so it's a cold plant. No, what's your name? It's like a, it's just the original cold plant. Just having, but I go straight in. It's a cold plunge. It's like a
所以我们现在回国了，对吧？我当时仍然每天在海里游泳。海水冰冷刺骨。非常冷。对。挺冷的，但我直接就下去了。所以这就是冷水浸泡。不，你叫什么？这就像是个，这只是最初的冷水浸泡。就是泡一下，但我直接就下去了。这是冷水浸泡。这就像是
just the original cold plunge, it's having a cold swim in the ocean. I do the same thing. And I go back home in LA, I start every day with I had the sun as well, which I do later in the day with the cold. But in the morning, I do just straight into the cold plunge. Yeah. How long? How long do you? Like the other day, you know, if I can make it three minutes, then I'll be, then that's good. But you, but usually about two minutes. I mean, I'm too. In the morning. Yeah. Oh, that's it. I was told that you got to make it four. And I thought, I do. I was like, I was like, I do 30 minutes. Yeah. Three minutes.
最初的冷水浸泡，就像在海里洗了个冷水澡。我也这么做。我回到洛杉矶的家中，我每天的一开始都是，我也蒸桑拿，我通常在晚些时候结合冷水浴来做。但在早上，我直接就去进行冷水浸泡。对。多久？你泡多久？像前几天，你知道的，如果我能坚持三分钟，那我就，那挺好的。但你，通常大约两分钟。我是说，两分钟。在早上。对。哦，就这样。有人告诉我你得坚持四分钟。我想，我做到了。我想，我会说，我做30分钟。对。三分钟。
But I keep my, I keep mine at 39 degrees. So it's very cold. That's the idea. Mine's not that cold. Mine's probably 45. It's not 30. Is there a way to do it where you build up the tolerance to the cold? Yeah, it's only for 30 seconds. That's even cooler. But it does everything. It reduces inflammation.
但我把温度保持在39华氏度。所以非常冷。这就是诀窍。我的没那么冷。我的大概45度。不是30度。有没有什么方法可以慢慢建立对寒冷的耐受力？对，只要30秒。那就更酷了。但它什么都能做。它能减少炎症。
The benefits of it are so if you can do basically, if you can build it up, I forget what the actual number is, but it's something, it's not even that much. It's like if you can do 10 minutes, cumulative minutes per week, it does x-ball benefits. And inflammation is the root of all, now we sound like Huberman super layoff. I mean, hey, can you do like a frog boil type of strategy
它的好处非常多，如果你能做到基本上，如果你能慢慢增加，我忘了具体的数字是多少，但大概是，甚至不需要那么多。如果你每周能积累10分钟，它就能带来各种好处。而炎症是一切的根源，现在我们听起来就像胡伯曼（Huberman）的超级粉丝了。我是说，嘿，你能用那种煮青蛙的策略
with it where it starts sort of room temperature and then you progressively get it colder and colder and you end up staying in there for 20 minutes, you know, because you don't really notice it getting colder. Right. I guess, man. I don't know. I don't work for the fucking pool company, dude. Back to real.
来搞这个吗？从室温开始，然后逐渐让它变得越来越冷，最后你在里面待上20分钟，你知道的，因为你并没有真正察觉到它变得越来越冷。对吧，老兄。我不知道。我又不在泳池公司上班，老兄。回到现实。
You got it. How long have you, can you do it for Jason? It's just the first time I think I was two or three minutes. Okay, yeah. It felt all right, but how did you handle that, Jason? Like going, you're, you're, you go junk right away or did you go slowly? No, I went right away, but it was after the sun. So it was deep sweat. I was, I've never been hotter.
你懂的。杰森，你能坚持多久？我想第一次我大概待了两三分钟。好的，对，感觉还行，但你是怎么应对的，杰森？就那种，你是，你直接跳进去，还是慢慢来的？不，我是直接进去的，但那是在桑拿之后。所以是大汗淋漓之后。我从来没有那么热过。
And then, yeah, that's, that makes it. So like, as, as I've been building it, so by the time, Jay, you get here, the new one will be built. So as I've been waiting for it for the last year I have this is true I've this big inflatable Temporary tub out here and and I go and I'll get like eight 10 bags of ice and I fill it in and I with with water And I make this big slushy ice thing and I and I do it like that. I sit in the ice. Oh, that's cool Yeah, Rose, I want to talk about your family
然后，对，那就对了。所以，在我建造的过程中，等到杰森你来到这里时，新的浴池就建好了。所以在我过去一年等待它的过程中，我这里有一个巨大的充气临时浴缸，然后我会去买八到十袋冰块，把它倒进去，加满水。我弄了这么一大堆冰沙似的东西，我就那样做。我坐在冰里。哦，太酷了。对，露丝，我想聊聊你的家庭
so listen when you and I do it like that. And I sit in the ice. That's cool. Yeah. Rose, I want to talk about your family. So listen, when you, what was it like growing up? Did you get pushed into this? Is it something you wanted to do? How did you get exposed to doing the thing you love to do? Well, I grew up in a neighborhood called Balmain. And there was a lot of kids in my neighborhood who used to go to the Australian theater for young people,
所以听着，当你和我一起这么做。我坐在冰里。太酷了。对。露丝，我想聊聊你的家庭。所以听着，当你，成长经历是怎样的？你被强迫走这条路吗？这是你想做的事吗？你是怎么接触到你热爱的事业的？嗯，我在一个叫巴尔曼的街区长大。我那个街区有很多孩子以前常去澳大利亚青年剧院，
which is ATYP. And I, friends of a friend of mine was like, I think you'd really like it. And I was only little, I was eight. And that's how I started was just doing these classes after school and just loved it. Oh, really? Just loved it.
也就是ATYP。我，我一个朋友的朋友说，觉得我一定会喜欢。那时我还很小，才八岁。我就是这样开始的，放学后去上这些表演课，然后就爱上了。哦，真的吗？就是很喜欢。
Anybody else in your family and do it? No, none of my siblings, not my parents, anything. The neighborhood we were in was, you know, somewhat Bohemian, I guess, sort of a lot of artists there at the time. It's a bit more gentrified now. But that was, yeah, that was how I started. It was going to ATYP, yeah, doing classes.
你家里还有其他人做这行吗？没有，我的兄弟姐妹都没有，父母也没有，什么都没有。我们所在的街区，你知道的，多少有点波西米亚风格，我想，那时那里有很多艺术家。现在中产阶级化更严重一些。但那就是，对，我就是那样开始的。去ATYP，对，上课。
Has your favorite part of it changed at all? Or do you still love the same things? Um, I, yeah, I, I mean, I still get nervous. I still get nervous before every job. I still get panicked and think, how am I going to do this? How am I not going to screw this up? Like, I feel like the nerves are still there about it. Like I don't know if the actor's condition
你对这行的最爱有什么改变吗？还是你依然热爱同样的事情？嗯，我，对，我，我是说，我还是会紧张。每次工作前我还是会紧张。我还是会恐慌，心想，我该怎么做？我怎么才能不把这搞砸？就像，我感觉那种紧张感一直都在，关于这件事。就像我不知道演员的这种状态
is sort of, you can't really change it. Right, do you guys feel like that? Yeah, I mean at any time I'm calm, I end up doing a terrible job. A little bit of nerves keeps me focused. I think so too. I think so too. You know, but.
是不是那种，你真的无法改变的东西。对吧，你们有这种感觉吗？对，我是说，任何时候只要我感到平静，我最后就会把工作搞得一团糟。有点紧张感能让我保持专注。我也这么觉得。我也这么觉得。你知道的，但是。
But you know, it's funny though, but you know, for somebody who you say that you get nervous or whatever, and I mentioned this before, you're always working, you have two shows in a movie out right now as of the time of this broadcast. You've got physical, your show physical, which is your thing about it said in the 80s, where you play this sort of like a housewife who's kind of discontented. I mean, there's more than that, but that's the log line I'm going to give you.
但你知道，这很有趣，对吧，对于一个你说自己会紧张或者别的什么的人，我之前也提到过，你一直在工作，在本节目播出时，你同时有两部剧和一部电影上映。你有《健美mimi》，你的那部关于80年代背景的剧，你在里面扮演一个有点不满现状的家庭主妇。我的意思是，不仅如此，但这大概是我给你的剧情梗概。
And then you've got Platonic with Seth Rogan, right, the show where you guys play best friends who haven't put on it. And then you have Insidious. And I'm like, yeah, this is like that, to have three major things out at the same time. I mean, it's unusual and it's a lot. Please, you have freedom to complain, go. Yeah. That's a lot.
然后你还有和塞斯·罗根合作的《伯纳黛特你去了哪》——不对，是《柏拉图式关系》，对吧，你们在剧中扮演多年未见的好朋友。然后你还有《潜伏》。我就想，对，这就是这样，同时有三部大作品上映。我的意思是，这很不寻常，而且量很大。请吧，你有权利抱怨，请开始。对。这量真大。
Well, all the pressure. And do you feel the end? The press, exactly. So the press alone that you have to do for that stuff. And a little bit is like, be careful what you wish for. Do you ever feel like that? I mean, I'm honestly just you got to make a little bit, it's such a sort of, but I feel like when I've, you know,
全都是压力。你感受到压力了吗？宣传，没错。光是为了这些作品你得做的宣传。这有点像，小心你的愿望成真。你有时会有这种感觉吗？我是说，老实说，你必须付出一点，这真是一种，但我觉得每当我，你知道的，
get, it's judged by job, right? Like, when I got the scripts for physical, this was a few years ago, but it was just such an interesting premise and pilot and like a character I'd never really seen before, setting this really specific world of like, you know, how, you know, how the, how the wellness industry really began, you know, sort of reverse, reverse engineering that and that, and really looking at this illness of bulimia, which is something that's never really been examined before on screen in a way that wasn't like a punchline or wasn't sort of, you know,
接戏，都是一部戏一部戏地评估，对吧？就像，当我拿到《健美mimi》的剧本时，那是几年前的事了，但它有着如此有趣的设定和试播集，以及一个我从未真正见过的角色，设定在这个非常独特的健康产业真正起步的世界里，你知道的，有点像逆向工程，真正审视暴食症这种病症，这在银幕上从未被真正探讨过，不是作为一种笑料，也不是某种，你知道的，
and this was doing it in a way that I thought was really interesting and it's really anyways in story. She's the creator and she's been very much a touchstone for me in terms of like how we represent it. But I don't know about you guys, but I just always feel like the last job you do is maybe the last job you'll ever get. Oh, I don't know. I always feel so fortunate to get another job. Yeah, I'm like, it feels so hot, you know? It's this business that doesn't know on anyone's favorites, really, like it's so I very much have that.
而且这部剧以一种我认为非常有趣且引人入胜的故事方式在展现。她是创作者，在如何呈现这个题材方面，她一直是我非常重要的风向标。但我不知道你们怎么想，但我总觉得你拍的上一部作品可能是你这辈子接到的最后一部作品。哦，我不知道。我总是觉得自己能接到下一部作品是如此幸运。对，我就想，这感觉太难了，你知道吗？这个行业对谁都不是偏爱，真的，它太，所以我非常有这种感觉。
We'll be right back. Smartlis has brought to you in part by State Farm. Hey, Smartlis listener, think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you. For instance, the song you stream over and over again while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at 4 in the morning with all the light top trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut from the 90s and hopefully is, everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way.
我们马上回来。《聪明笨蛋》由State Farm部分赞助播出。嘿，《聪明笨蛋》的听众们，想想生活中那些表达真我、独一无二的奇妙事物吧。比如，凌晨四点，当你关掉所有灯、极力避免吵醒室友、在进行第13个小时的游戏时，一遍又一遍单曲循环的那首歌；或者你在去健身房的路上最适合听的六大喜剧播客中分享给朋友们的推荐；又或是你的新发型——这可能也可能不是90年代史诗级的锅盖头，但愿是的——所有造就了“独一无二的你”的事物，都意义非凡。State Farm坚信保险也该如此。
Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you. And the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you like choosing to bundle your home or audio policies is what the state farm personal price plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you. So are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to statefarm.com today to create your state farm personal price plan. Price is vary by state, options selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. We're brought to you in part by GoodRx. Are you one of the millions of Americans affected by changes in your insurance status or loss of Medicaid? GoodRx is here to help with easy prescription
你的计划，你的险种选择可以完全由你自己个性化定制。能够通过挑选适合你的选项来选择你想要的计划——就像选择将你的房屋或汽车保单捆绑在一起一样——这就是State Farm个人价格计划的全部意义所在。以实惠的价格获得专属于你的心仪保障。所以，准备好让一切变得个性化了吗？今天就致电或访问statefarm.com，创建你的State Farm个人价格计划。价格因州而异，客户选择的选项、可用性和资格可能会有所不同。本节目由GoodRx部分赞助播出。你是否也是数百万受保险状态改变或失去医疗白卡影响的美国人之一？GoodRx旨在通过简单的处方药省钱方案和直观的指导来帮助你应对保障范围的变化。
savings and straightforward guidance for navigating changes in coverage. With goodRx, you can instantly find discounts and save up to 80% on retail prescription prices. And goodRx is totally free and simple to use. All you need to do is search for your prescription on the goodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy counter. It's that easy. GoodRx is accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CVS, Kroger, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vans, Walmart, Sam's Club,
通过GoodRx，你可以立即找到折扣，在零售处方药价格上节省高达80%的费用。而且GoodRx完全免费且使用简单。你所需要做的就是在GoodRx网站或应用程序上搜索你的处方药，并在药房柜台出示你的折扣。就这么简单。GoodRx被你社区中所有主要药房接受，包括CVS、Kroger、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club，
and many, many more. And remember, goodRx doesn't just work for new prescriptions. It can help you save big on all of your refills, too. I have a friend who was discussing not necessarily complaining, but discussing about how much his medications cost. And I told him about goodRx and he used it and he raved about it.
以及许多许多其他药房。记住，GoodRx不仅适用于新处方。它也能帮你大大节省所有续药的费用。我有个朋友之前在讨论——倒不是抱怨，而是在讨论他的药物花了多少钱。我跟他说了GoodRx，他用了之后赞不绝口。
Talked to me like a week later saying how much money he's saved. And I'm so happy for him, truly. So to start saving on prescription regardless of your coverage status, check GoodRx. Go to goodrx.com slash smartless. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. GoodRx is not insurance. and now back to the show. And then like I said, you like you started and you did a lot of dramatic stuff
大约一周后他跟我聊天，说他省了多少钱。我真的为他感到高兴。所以，无论你的保障状态如何，要想开始在处方药上省钱，请查看GoodRx。访问goodrx.com/smartless。也就是goodrx.com/smartless。GoodRx不是保险。现在回到节目中。然后就像我说的，你刚开始时拍了很多剧情片，
and you did a lot of like huge movies you did. I mean, kind of, I sort of forgotten that you had done Troy all those years ago, which is so crazy. It might seem like a different lifetime ago, a little bit, right? Yeah, I was so glad. Talking about working on that, because that was in Malta, right? Yeah, I was.
拍了很多大电影。我的意思是，差不多，我差点忘了你多年前演过《特洛伊》，这太疯狂了。那感觉可能像是上辈子的事了，有点像，对吧？对，我太高兴了。聊聊在那里的工作经历吧，因为那是在马耳他拍的，对吧？对，是的。
Yeah, I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. you had done Troy all those years ago, which is so crazy. It might seem like a different lifetime ago, a little bit, right? Yeah, I was so glad. Talk about working on that, because that was in Malta, right? Yeah, in Malta. Jason's Maltese. Yeah.
对，是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。是的。你多年前演过《特洛伊》，这太疯狂了。那感觉可能像是上辈子的事了，有点像，对吧？对，我太高兴了。聊聊在那里的工作经历吧，因为那是在马耳他拍的，对吧？对，在马耳他。杰森是马耳他裔。对。
I am. No. My grandma, yeah, on my mom's side. Are you being serious? Yeah. Yeah, I didn't know that. Look at his fingers. Show us your fingers, Jay.
我是。没有。我奶奶，对，我妈妈那边。你是认真的吗？对。对，我不知道这个。看他的手指。把你的手指给我们看看，杰。
Look at those big fingers for hauling nets. Yeah, it says you're going to have a little bit fatter. So when you pull in the fish nets, you don't cut through to the bone. Yeah. And you're funny. And I've got webbed feed. If I fall off the boat, I can swim. Have you ever been there? Yeah. Once when I was a little kid, I would like to go back. Will you're thinking about going, aren't you, Willie? Yeah. We're supposed to go a couple weeks ago and then we we bailed. But yeah, yeah, I am going to go back. Will you're thinking about going, aren't you, Willie? Yeah. We were supposed to go a couple weeks ago and then we we bailed. But yeah, yeah, I am going to go, I think in this they used to shoot a lot there. They shot, yeah, they shot
看看那些用来拉网的大粗手指。对，说明你得长得稍微粗壮一点。这样当你拉渔网时，才不会割到骨头。对。而且你很有趣。我还有蹼足。如果我从船上掉下去，我能游走。你去过那里吗？对。小时候去过一次，我还想再去。威尔，你正考虑要去，对吧，威利？对。我们本来几周前要去，后来临时取消了。但对，对，我要去。威尔，你正考虑要去，对吧，威利？对。我们本来几周前要去，后来临时取消了。但对，对，我要去，我想他们以前经常在那里拍。他们拍过，对，他们拍过
their. They're going to do more. They're going to do more. They are. Yeah, they're about to do more. So you go to Malta to do Troy with Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt. I mean, how old were you when you did that? I was like 12. I don't know. I was so young, I was like 23, and just it was pretty overwhelming. I was extremely shy, like I was very, very shy, and I play like a, I played Bruce Sayers who gets like captured and thrown to him as like a toy that he can, you know, do what he wants with. So it was pretty funny.
他们的。他们还会去拍更多。他们还会去拍。他们会的。对，他们马上要去拍更多。所以你去马耳他跟布拉德·皮特一起拍《特洛伊》。布拉德·皮特。我的意思是，你拍那部电影时多大？我大概12岁。不知道。我当时太年轻了，大概23岁，简直有点不知所措。我极其害羞，非常非常害羞，我扮演的是一个……我扮演的是布里塞伊斯，她被俘虏并作为一件玩具扔给他，让他可以，你知道的，对她为所欲为。所以挺搞笑的。
It's a lot of, you know, me tied up, like, excuse me, so I do what he wants with. So it was pretty funny. It's a lot of me tied up, but excuse me, so I do what you do. No, like, beast, you know, like that. It was very, very, very, very. Don't you kiss me on the mouth. You know, and yeah, I was really shy. So how did that come about? Like, what was the process?
有很多，你知道的，我被绑起来，像，不好意思，所以对他为所欲为。所以挺搞笑的。有很多我被绑起来的镜头，不好意思，所以你做什么。不，就像，野兽，你知道的，就像那样。非常非常非常。别在嘴上亲我。你知道的，对，我真的很害羞。那这个角色是怎么得来的？流程是怎样的？
I had done this movie called Wicker Park. This movie with Diane Krueger and Josh Hartnett and Matthew Lillard like in Montreal and from there I got an auditioned for Troy and a weirdly Diane Krueger also she played Hellenem Troy so we like spent two years together back like you know 20 years ago, yeah, it was such a huge insane budget and so many extras and so many, it was just, you know, a Peter O'Toole was in the movie. I remember, you know, he would be smoking, you know, he was incredible, you know, this legendary actor and he was very fond of us of me and we hit it off. We kind of got along and really well. And I remember him climbing the stairs of like one of the ancient ruins that we were filming at
我当时拍过一部叫《迷情公寓》的电影。这部电影有黛安·克鲁格、乔什·哈奈特和马修·莉沃德，在蒙特利尔拍的。从那之后我去试镜了《特洛伊》，而且很巧的是，黛安·克鲁格也出演了，她饰演海伦，所以我们大约在20年前一起度过了两年时光，对，那是如此巨大、疯狂的预算，有那么多的群众演员，有那么多的，你知道的，彼得·奥图尔也在电影里。我记得，你知道的，他会抽烟，你知道的，他太不可思议了，你知道的，这位传奇演员，他非常喜欢我们——我，我们很合得来。我们相处得非常融洽。我记得他当时正爬着我们正在拍摄的一个古代遗址的阶梯，
and really breathing really hardly. You don't like going out the stairs and one of the PA's saying to him, I think you might have to give up the ciggy's Pete or something and he was like, oh, I should just give up the stairs. Uh-huh. And you're fired. That's the stairs. Uh-huh. Yeah.
喘气喘得非常厉害。你不喜欢爬楼梯，然后其中一个制片助理对他说，彼得，我想你可能得把烟戒了什么的，然后他说，哦，我应该戒掉楼梯。呃哼。你被解雇了。那是楼梯。呃哼。对。
And you're fired. That's so good. What an answer. I know it was good. He had all this. One of my dumb questions is, how hard is the American accent? I like asking people that. I know I love that.
你被解雇了。太棒了。多妙的回答。我知道这太棒了。他有这些。我的一个蠢问题是，美国口音有多难？我喜欢问别人这个。我知道，我喜欢这个。
Do you have a word that clicks you into it? Because you have such a great American accent. Oh, thanks, Paul. We had a lot of American TV in Australia, so I grew up watching Seinfeld and family ties and stuff like that. Yeah, so you learned the American accent from my sister? Is that what you're saying? Yeah, I mean, it sounded a little like justine.
你有什么词能帮你瞬间进入状态吗？因为你的美国口音太棒了。哦，谢谢，保罗。我们在澳大利亚看了很多美国电视，所以我从小看《宋飞正传》和《结发夫妻》之类的情景喜剧长大。对，所以你是从我妹妹那里学到美国口音的？你是这个意思吗？对，我是说，听起来有点像贾斯汀。
I don't know. But I had this really hard dialogue once when I did damages. When I still say it to try, if I'm having fun, patty hired 24-hour security for Katie. Wow. That's what's the power. Patty hired 24-hour security for Katie. Wow. What is that?
我不知道。但我拍《蓝海奇缘》时有一句很难的台词。直到现在我试镜时还在说，如果我在找乐子的话，帕蒂为凯蒂雇了24小时安保。哇。这就是权势。帕蒂为凯蒂雇了24小时安保。哇。那是什么？
What is that? What is that from? It's a damage. It's a damage. It's a damage. So ours are tough. Yeah, and the hydred. Patty hired.
那是什么？那是出自哪里？是《蓝海奇缘》。是《蓝海奇缘》。是《蓝海奇缘》。所以“hired”很难。对，还有“hired”。
That's a hard one. Higher. How do you say hired in Australian? Highed. Highed. Highed. Highed. Higher.
这太难了。“Hired”。澳大利亚人是怎么发“hired”这个音的？“Highed”。“Highed”。“Highed”。“Higher”。
Higher. Higher. 24-. Security for kids. Yeah, we just, we just sound sort of efficient and great to sort of like that, that is true. We sound like a bunch of knobs. Yeah, let's be honest. That was really, that's my, that's my go to one I've done. But, um, but I love it. I kind of, if I don't have to do an accent, I feel a bit strange.
“Higher”。“Higher”。24——凯蒂的安保。对，我们，我们听起来就是那种效率很高又很棒的感觉，大概就是那样，确实如此。我们听起来像是一群讨厌鬼。对，说实话。那是我的，那是我的拿手绝活。但是，但我喜欢。我感觉，如果我不需要说口音，我会觉得有点奇怪。
Like on Platonic, there was this whole mixed-hole I really wanted me to be Australian. And I was very much like, I'm not sure I don't have to do an accent, I feel a bit strange. Like on Platonic, there was this whole next doll I really wanted me to be Australian. And I was very much like, I'm not sure, I don't know. I just want to, you know, I'm quite, but then anyway, I agreed to do it. You did, Australian, but you were kind of, there were moments where you sounded cut, not totally yourself, kind of. A little bit right?
就像在拍《柏拉图式关系》时，下一场戏的整个剧组真的希望我是澳大利亚人。我当时非常坚持，我不确定如果不说口音，我感觉会有点奇怪。就像在拍《柏拉图式关系》时，下一场戏的整个剧组真的希望我是澳大利亚人。我当时非常坚持，我不确定，我不知道。我只是想，你知道的，我很，但无论如何，我最后还是同意了。你演了，澳大利亚口音，但你某种程度上，有些时刻你听起来不太，完全不像你自己，有点。有点对吧？
Yeah. In Platonic, I noticed that, because I watched it, I noticed that. Yeah. And you're so good in it Rose. You're so so With your countryman, sir. I know with Seth. I love we love and a friend of the show. We love Seth You you must love working with him. You've done a few things. You guys have done a bunch He's a great dude Rose a fan a fan of question, were you, was Bride's man, are you getting eagles from fans right now?
对。在《柏拉图式关系》里我注意到了，因为我看过，我注意到了。对。你在里面演得真好，露丝。你太棒了。跟你的同胞一起，先生。我知道，还有塞斯。我喜欢，我们都爱，作为节目的老朋友，我们都爱塞斯。你一定很喜欢跟他合作。你们合作过好多次了。你们合作过一堆东西。他是个很棒的家伙，露丝，粉丝的提问，你是，是《伴娘》吗，你现在从粉丝那里收到很多这样的评价吗？
Yeah, was Bride's man as much fun making it as it is watching it, because I remember I went opening weekend, and I, yeah, back in the day. And I'm over. I was, I, it just come out, not too many people were talking about it, I was like the second day it was out or something. And I was kind of, I'm the one who told everybody about it.
对，《伴娘》拍的时候像看的时候那么好玩吗？因为我记得我去看首映周末场，我，对，在那个年代。而且我。我，它刚上映，没多少人在谈论它，大概是上映的第二天还是什么时候。而且我有点，我是那个到处跟别人安利它的人。
No, and I remember emailing Wig and I'm just like, oh my god, I love that movie so much. And it was just, and then just became this huge thing. Exploded. But it's just, it's one of my favorite movies, it's one of billions of people's favorite movies all the time. But it looks like it was a blast
不，我记得我给维格发邮件说，哦，天哪，我太喜欢这部电影了。然后它就，然后就变成了一件轰动的事。大火。但它就是，这是我最喜欢的电影之一，也是全世界数十亿人一直以来最喜欢的电影之一。但看起来当时拍得非常开心，
and you laughed every single day. And we did. It was one of those jobs where it definitely did have no idea that it would become such a beloved film at all. It was like a mid-sized film. It wasn't, you know, it was like, yeah. What was weird was acting with that many women, I must say.
而且你们每天都在笑。确实如此。那是那种你完全不知道它会成为如此备受喜爱的电影的工作之一。它就像是一部中等规模的电影。它不是，你知道的，它就是，对。最奇怪的是和那么多女性一起演戏，我必须得说。
That was bizarre. Like the big days when we had all those set pieces and it was just like eight women or, you know, all of the girls together, that was really unusual. Cause usually if you're in a film, there's not often you're the only woman or you're doing a scene opposite a guy
那太奇妙了。就像那些有所有大场景的日子，现场只有大约八个女性，或者，你知道的，所有的女孩聚在一起，那真的非常不寻常。因为通常如果你在拍电影，往往不会只有你一个女性，或者你是在跟一个男人演对手戏，
or it's very rare to have that. And that was, I remember thinking in those days, we're so fun. Cause we all really hit it off. It was like not, it was a very good vibe on set, and everybody was really fun. How often do you and Bobby get to work together? We've been, we've worked together a lot.
或者有这种阵容的情况非常罕见。我记得当时在那些日子里我想，太有趣了。因为我们真的很合得来。片场的气氛非常好，每个人都非常有趣。你和博比多久能一起工作一次？我们一直，我们合作过很多次。
Jason, actually, yeah, we did Medea together at BAM right before the pandemic hit, which was pretty wild, because we saw that kind of coming in, like the audience is starting to slow down and New York starting to shut down and just word about what's happening is this thing and then we had our final show and then three days later the whole of Broadway shut down and I remember hearing, oh, there's a male show had it
杰森，其实，对，大流行爆发前不久我们在BAM一起演过《美狄亚》，这挺疯狂的，因为我们当时有点预见到那种情况了，比如观众开始变少，纽约开始封城，关于正发生的事各种传言四起，然后我们演了最后一场演出，三天后整个百老汇就关门了。我记得听到，哦，某个梅尔的剧也关了，
and someone else and then and then New York just was like the apocalypse. Were you guys in New York or were you a pro? We're during the pandemic. Because me and the guys on the other podcast we have like real heavy duty opinions about it. The plan. The plan. The future on all the other podcasts. We got real opinions about what you government. It was such a. We were all in, we were all in LA. You were all in LA. Yeah. Yeah. We were all in LA and, um, yeah in LA and yeah and Bert and Bert think this thing trying to find it
还有别的，然后纽约就变得像末日一样。你们当时在纽约还是在？我们在大流行期间。因为我和另一个播客的伙伴们对这件事有着非常强烈的看法。那项计划。那项计划。关于未来的所有其他播客。我们对你们政府的做法有着强烈的看法。那真是一个。我们当时都在洛杉矶。你们当时都在洛杉矶。对。对。我们都在洛杉矶，而且，是的，在洛杉矶，是的，伯特和伯特觉得这事想弄清楚
Yeah, sorry it didn't work out that well for you, huh? It's been a real It's been a bummer It's it's been a bummer, but you know what kind of kind of and I love I love bridesmaids too I mean bridesmaid is so, so funny. And obviously, Wigg is, you know, Chris and we love Paul Fee. Jason, I've worked with Paul before. He's great. He's such a great dude.
对，抱歉这事对你来说结果不太好，对吧？这真的是个，这真是个扫兴的事。这真的是个扫兴的事，但你知道吗，有点像，我喜欢，我也喜欢《伴娘》！我是说《伴娘》太好笑了，太好笑了。显然，维格是，你知道的，克里斯汀，我们都很爱保罗·费格。杰森，我以前和保罗合作过。他太棒了。他是个极好的家伙。
And... Always in a suit. Always in a suit. Always in a suit. Always in a shirt. Always in a shirt. He had one of those VW bugs when they first came out. And you remember the little Vaws that they have in the front?
而且……永远一身西装。永远一身西装。永远一身西装。永远穿着衬衫。永远穿着衬衫。他有一辆大众甲壳虫，就是刚出来的那种。你还记得他们前面那个小花瓶吗？
He had a little flower in his Vaws. Yeah. Yeah, right on the dashboard. He's just a classy guy. He's a classy guy and his wife is awesome. He's just a cool dude. But everybody in that movie and obviously Melissa and everybody just such a great cast. And Maya, so you've done that. You have to get about Ben Falcon.
他花瓶里插着一朵小花。对。对，就在仪表盘上。他就是个有品位的家伙。他是个有品位的人，他妻子也很棒。他就是个很酷的家伙。但那部电影里的每个人，显然还有梅丽莎和所有人都构成了这么棒的演员阵容。还有玛娅，所以你演过那个。你得说说本·法尔科内。
And Ben Falcon, the great Ben Falcon. Who we love. I know. Now we're going to get texts from Ben Falcone. How did you not mention me? We did. Barely got it in there, Will. I know. Well, now Ben doesn't have to text us.
还有本·法尔科内，伟大的本·法尔科内。我们深爱的本·法尔科内。我知道。现在我们要收到本·法尔科内的短信了。你怎么没提到我？我们提了。好不容易才塞进去的，威尔。我知道。好吧，现在本不用给我们发短信了。
But then, so you do that, then you do, you start doing more and more comedy. And then, but you can also seamlessly go back. My question for you is, is there something that you haven't, because it feels like you can kind of do everything, is there something that you're like, what's the big thing that's out there that you haven't done yet that you're like, I want to do something like X? Is there something that kind of in the back your mind that's... Or stuff they don't call you for? Yeah. Why don't they call me for that stuff? Oh my gosh. I mean, for me, I feel like comedy and drama, like the stakes are even higher in comedy.
但是，然后，你做了那个，接着你开始演越来越多的喜剧。然后，但你也能无缝切换回去。我给你的问题是，有没有什么是你还没——因为感觉你好像什么都能演——有没有什么是你在想，外面还有什么大项目是你没演过、让你觉得“我想演X那种角色”的？有没有什么东西藏在你脑海深处……或者说他们不找你演的类型？对。为什么他们不找我演那种角色？天哪。我是说，对我而言，我觉得喜剧和剧情片，喜剧里的赌注其实更高。
I think to make something funny is like, it is fun and all that stuff, but it's also, it's hard work in a different way. You know, like it's... But what's great about you is you never ask for any laughs. You know, you're always so great about... You know, some people, when they... you're always so great about you know, some people when they when they some dramatic actors have tried to play comedy, they they
我觉得创作搞笑的东西吧，挺好玩的，但也是另一种辛苦。你知道的，就像是……不过你最棒的一点是，你从来不会刻意讨笑。你知道的，你总是……有些人，当他们……你总是那么擅长，你知道的，有些人当他们……有些戏剧演员尝试去演喜剧时，他们……
just sort of like speak louder and make faces. You just keep it all very relatable and grounded and real and your brand of humor. I just for me just I love it. Oh hell yeah. Yeah. Well, let's say what about like playing what about somebody with a limp and a list and old age makeup and like that kind of character I was excited about. I would like to play We could arrange that Actually, I'll joke the side hamlet as a comedy. Something is really funny. It'd be called hamlet and cheese.
只会大声说话然后做鬼脸。而你总是能保持内容的真实感、接地气和生活化，你的这种幽默风格，我个人真的非常喜欢。哦，天哪，是的。好吧，那如果说……比如去演一个什么样的人呢？比如一个有点跛脚、说话漏风、顶着老年妆的那种角色，我之前还挺兴奋的。我很想去演……我们完全可以安排一下。说实话，抛开玩笑不谈，把《哈姆雷特》演成喜剧，那一定非常有意思。可以叫《哈姆雷特与奶酪》。
Yeah. Oh. I think we figured it out, guys. I'm going to pull CIA. I'm going to put it together. Bobby can play Ocelio. Ocelio. I'll feel yo.
对。哦。我想我们搞定啦，伙计们。我要去联系中情局了。我要把它促成。鲍比可以演奥赛罗。奥赛罗。我会觉得你的。
I'll feel yo. I'm going to a little wig and a little dress. He'll be cute. I feel yo. I feel yo. But there's nothing that you're like, oh man, you don't like sit there and like talk to your friends at night. Why am I not getting this?
我会觉得你的。我要穿一件小裙子戴一顶小假发。他会很可爱的。我感觉到了。我感觉到了。不过没有什么事情会让你觉得，天哪，你不会大晚上坐在那儿跟朋友聊天时想：为什么我没接到这个角色？
I imagine that you're always talking to your friends saying me. Is there somebody like a historical figure you'd want to ever play or somebody like in the public eye or some part you ever like really aching to do? Well, I did this show Mrs. America and it was set in the second way feminist movement and I played Gloria Steinem and that was extraordinary. I must say and I learned a lot of pressure. Obviously she's still reactive and you know she's extraordinary but that was really no fracking and that was definitely something I tried to get out of because I was like, I thought the first time
我想你总是跟朋友们说：为什么是我。有没有什么历史人物是你一直想演的，或者是公众眼中的某个人，又或者是某个你一直渴望去尝试的角色？嗯，我演过一部叫《美国夫人》的剧，背景是第二波女性主义运动，我演的是格洛丽亚·斯泰纳姆，那真是一段非凡的经历。我必须得说，我压力也很大。显然她现在还在活跃，而且你知道她很了不起，但那真的让人胆战心惊，那绝对是我曾试图推掉的角色，因为我觉得，这是你第一次……
you played a real person? I threw that up. I have played Duchess to Polanyak in Sophia Coppola's Rand-Toinette, obviously Curson has, but I played a very, it was a very, very small pop, but she was a real person. Yeah, she was like, good time to go. Yeah, but nobody can really re-
演一个真实存在的人？我以前演过。在索菲亚·科波拉的《绝代艳后》里我演过波利尼亚克公爵夫人，虽然克尔斯滕演的是主角，但我演了一个非常、非常小的角色，但她确实是个真人。对，她当时就属于那种：该退场了。对，但其实没人能……
nobody can really reference her and go, like, hey, she'd talk like that. Right, yeah, yeah. She put her in her hair on the right side. She's a little more obscure. Oh yeah, you're right. Yeah, you haven't heard of that. You haven't heard of it.
没人能真正参照着她然后说：嘿，她就是这么说话的。对，没错，没错。她把头发别在右边。她稍微有点名不见经传。哦对，你说得对。对，你可能都没听说过。你肯定没听说过。
So were you pressured like having to do an impersonation or an accurate one, or did you kind of like do your version of her? Well, she's so different from me where she came from and grew up in Sanford. So it was a lot of technical work like that, but it was really fun. It was really, eventually it was really fun. And her look is just so specific, like her silhouette is so iconic. So it was just like trying to like get that silhouette. She's one of those few people that you know immediately kind of who she is. So just by her silhouette, so that was really nerve-wracking trying to
所以你当时会有压力，必须得去模仿她或者力求精准，还是说你只是在演你自己的版本？嗯，她跟我的背景很不一样，她是在桑福德长大的。所以有很多这样的技术活，但真的很有趣。最后真的非常有趣。而且她的外形非常有辨识度，她的剪影太标志性了。所以当时就像是努力去还原那个剪影。她是那种你只要看到剪影就能立刻认出她是谁的人，所以为了还原这个，真的让人压力很大，试图去……
try and get that right and the voice and how she walks, so that was really nerve-wracking, trying to get that right and the voice and how she walks and all that was very, very specific, but really fun. But I mean, gosh, I'm inspired by so much stuff I see. Like I loved everything every year, once I thought that genre was great. I'd love to try it like that kind of wild genre, something I've never really, I've never been part of. That would be really, it's all about directors, right guys? Guys? Guys?
试图把它做好，包括声音和走路的姿势，所有这些都非常非常具体，但也真的很有趣。不过说实话，天哪，我被我看到的很多东西所激励。比如我非常喜欢每一年的作品，只要我觉得那个类型很棒。我很想尝试那种疯狂的类型，某种我从未真正接触过的、我从未参与过的东西。那真的会……一切都取决于导演，对吧，伙计们？伙计们？伙计们？
What do you do to, what's your thing you do to just sort of goof off? What's your down time thing? Yeah, you're watching like dumb TV to unwind. Are you a bike rider? Are you a cold lunch guy? Cold lunch guy? Yeah. Are you the cold lunch?
你平时都是怎么放松的？你用来偷懒解压的方式是什么？你闲暇时会做些什么？对，你会看一些无脑的电视节目来放松吗？你喜欢骑自行车吗？你是那种吃冷食的人吗？吃冷食的人？对。你是那个冷食派吗？
You do the cold lunch guy? I try to do that two or three times a week. And I'm, God, what else do I do? Are you a book reader? I do a book reader. I'm a book reader. And I'll watch a bad TV. Like Bobby thinks I'm pretty trashy.
你喜欢吃冷食吗？我尽量一周吃两三次。还有，天哪，我还做什么？你喜欢看书吗？我是一个读书的人。我喜欢看书。我还会看一些烂剧。比如鲍比觉得我的品味挺低俗的。
Like he's like, baby, why are you doing it? Why are you watching that? Yeah, you ever pulled him down into your little cesspool of reality TV? No, he just wants to watch sport. I don't know. Yeah. What's he addicted to? I get caught watching golf all the time and I'm very embarrassed.
就像他会说：宝贝，你为什么要看这个？你为什么要看那个？对，你有没有把他拉进你那真人秀的粪坑里过？没有，他只想看体育节目。我不知道。对。他沉迷于什么？我经常抓到他在看高尔夫，然后他会觉得很尴尬。
He's got a big live draft he does with like- Football fantasy. Rod and, oh sure. And all those guys, they do a big live draft every year. This year, they're not sure if they can do it, because there's some scheduling issues going on, so he's deeply unhappy. He's very unhappy. That's right.
他有个很大的实况选秀，跟一群人一起……梦幻橄榄球。罗德还有，哦当然。所有那些人，他们每年都会搞一个盛大的实况选秀。今年他们还不确定能不能办，因为有些赛程上的冲突，所以他非常不开心。他非常不开心。没错。
But he loves the football. He loves the footy. And I've grown to like it. I don't quite understand it, but I'm, you know, I try to get into it. I think it's good to get into sports. It's a good like... It's a good TV product.
但他就是超级热爱橄榄球。他热爱橄榄球运动。而我也渐渐喜欢上了。我虽然不太懂，但你知道的，我也在试着去了解。我觉得喜欢体育运动挺不错的。这算是一个挺好……这是一个挺棒的电视节目。
It's a design around advertising, right? Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah. It's a money maker. Yep. But I've been loving going to the theater. I saw a good night off, obviously.
它是围绕广告设计的，对吧？嗯哼。对。没错。这是一台印钞机。没错。不过我最近超级喜欢去剧院。显然我去看了一场《晚安，奥斯卡》。
And that's been great to get back. I should have felt like it was so quiet for a while, Sean. And then that feels like that's what Bobby and I loved. We just love to go to, we love to go to see shows. So that's been really fun to them. Yeah. And it is one of the great things about when you live in New York, you're being able to go and see. Yeah. Can I, can I ask, did you, have you had, Sean, have you had people on their phone, texting, phone calls? Yeah. Yeah.
能回归剧场真的太棒了。肖恩，我曾一度觉得剧场那边好安静啊。然后这就成了我和鲍比最喜欢做的事。我们就是喜欢去看演出。所以对我们来说这真的很有趣。对。而且在纽约生活的一大好处就是，你能经常去看演出。对。我能……我能问一下吗，肖恩，你有没有遇到过观众在看戏时玩手机、发短信、打电话的情况？有啊。有啊。
One time. What do you do? Do you do anything? Do you still feel certain? Yeah. One night, it was the perfect timing. It was, oh, shoot, I can't remember the line. Some phone was going off and I had a line.
有一次。那你怎么办？你会采取行动吗？你还会继续入戏吗？对。有天晚上，时机简直太完美了。当时是，哦糟了，我记不起台词了。正好有人的手机响了，而我当时正要接台词。
I told you guys I can't remember it is, but the line had to do with being quiet and I delivered it straight to that person. The audience. That whatever the line was. Did they laugh? Yeah, I got a little chuckle, little claps. Little claps. Because everybody, it's so annoying. But right in the middle of the last part where me and June,
我告诉过你们我记不得台词是什么了，但那句台词与安静有关，我是直接对那个人说的。对观众说的。不管那句台词是什么。他们笑了吗？对，我得到了轻微的笑声，还有稀疏的掌声。稀疏的掌声。因为每个人，这太烦人了。但在最后一部分的正中间，我和琼——
the girl playing my wife Emily, we were crying together and the phone, tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt t Dump, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, and so we're just like, and everybody in the theater is like, what the fuck? I just go, so completely ruined the moment. But what are you gonna do? Yeah. Anyway. Anyway. We've been fun having Sean on the podcast.
也就是扮演我妻子艾米丽的女孩，我们当时正一起哭，然后电话，叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮叮咚，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，笨，所以我们就觉得，剧场里的每个人都觉得，搞什么鬼？我刚说完，就把气氛全毁了。但你又能怎么办呢？好吧。不管怎样。不管怎样。肖恩来上播客我们玩得很开心。
Exactly. Rose, it is so fun hanging in, actually in a lot of ways was like all of a sudden like Rose is just kind of like the fourth. Yeah, thanks for letting Will and Sean and I catch up. Yeah. Like, you're just like, it's just like we're just hanging with Rose. That's the name of the episode. So easy to get along with Sean. So Sean and Rose, you guys don't know each other, right?
确实。罗斯，和大家一起聊天太开心了，其实在很多方面感觉突然之间罗斯就像是第四位嘉宾。对，谢谢你让威尔、肖恩和我聚在一起。对。就像，你就像，感觉我们就像在和罗斯一起聊天。这就是这期节目的名字。肖恩太容易相处了。所以肖恩和罗斯，你们俩之前不认识，对吧？
No, not really. But you guys would be great friends. I believe that. Do I think, Jay? Yeah. Yo, yeah, well, they're going to have a great time tonight. Rose is going to go back. Oh, yeah, go back.
不，不太认识。但你们俩一定会成为好朋友的。我坚信这点。我是这么想的吗，杰伊？对。哟，对，他们今晚会玩得很开心。罗斯要回去了。哦，对，回去了。
Yeah. Jump on the subway. Helping my sister's hands. He's going to get there. She's got a bag in front of her. She's holding a bag on the subway. Yeah. Just in case.
对。跳上地铁。顺便帮我姐姐的忙。他要到那儿去了。她前面背着个包。她在地铁上提着个包。对。以防万一。
I would love to see Bobby again, too. So we should grab a bite at this time. Oh, yeah, yeah. I'll tell him. Yeah. I'll tell him. Yeah I know Yeah, send Bobby our love He's one of the great guys and and thank you Rose for coming and do it I know your time and I was Topaz nervous. I was like oh my god
我也很想再见到鲍比。所以我们到时候应该一起吃个便饭。哦，对，对。我会告诉他的。对。我会告诉他的。对，我知道，对，代我们向鲍比问好。他是那种最好的人之一，谢谢罗斯能来参与，我知道你的时间，我当时紧张得要命。我当时想，哦，天哪
And drink a lot of electrolyte from your food toys Oh, we have a good advice. Thanks doc Okay and drink a lot of electrolyte from your food poisoning. Oh, we have a good advice. Thanks, Doc. Thank you. Okay. All right, we love you, Rose. Lots of love, Rose. Thank you. Thank you, guys. You too.
多补充电解质来缓解食物中毒噢，我们有个好建议。谢谢医生。好的。好吧，我们爱你，罗斯。满满的爱，罗斯。谢谢。谢谢你们。你们也是。
All right, bye, Rose. Bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Of course. Isn't she sweet, y'all? She is. That's very nice. Very nice.
好的，再见，罗斯。拜拜。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。当然。她不是很甜美吗，各位？她是的。这非常好。非常好。
She's such a town. She's done like a hundred movies. I know. She's been nominated for like Golden Globes, Emmys for everything she does. Boy, she's like stunningly beautiful. And she's gorgeous and she's smart as hell and she's and above everything else, she's so cool and down her earth. Yeah, she's like, I wonder what the, I wonder what's the bad thing? What's the blind spot? Yeah. Like what's she doing?
她真是一个大人物。她演过大约一百部电影。我知道。她因自己的作品获得过金球奖、艾美奖等各种提名。天哪，她美得惊艳。而且她光彩照人，聪明绝顶，最重要的是，她太酷了而且非常脚踏实地。是的，她就像是，我在想，我在想有什么不好的地方？有什么盲点吗？对。比如她在做什么？
She, she probably just got done with the podcast and threw all the equipment against the wall. Maybe she's nasty to babies. I said to some of these babies, it's just trigger something in her. I said to somebody recently, I said, I said, I said, I was talking to somebody I said, you know, you know, so and so he's got a real blind spot
她，她可能刚做完播客，就把所有设备都砸在墙上了。也许她对婴儿很刻薄。我对某些婴儿说过，这只是触动了她体内的某种开关。我最近对某个人说，我说，我说，我说，我当时在和某个人说话，我说，你知道，你知道，某某某他有一个真正的盲点
and they go, you know, everybody's got a blind spot and I said, I don't see mine Nice. Jesus. That's very good. Yeah. Yeah Um, but you know what I love because here goes shot here. I know get it. Sean. I got it. Jesus Christ Uh huh. I love her. I love her. Let's hear her. I love her so much. Sometimes I wonder if she thought that I might go by take another by to my tuna sandwich interviewing her there it is. Sean go ahead. Was that it? No, that's fine. Take another
他们说，你知道，每个人都有一个盲点，我说，我怎么没看到我的盲点。太棒了。天哪。这太妙了。对。对。嗯，但我最喜欢的是，因为肖恩来了。我知道，明白。肖恩。我懂了。天哪。嗯哼。我爱她。我爱她。让我们听听她的。我太爱她了。有时我在想，她是不是以为我可能会在采访她时去吃一口我的金枪鱼三明治。好了，肖恩，继续。是那样吗？不，那没关系。再吃一口
by my sandwich. Everybody can you are going to use now. Were you going to use bite? No, I was going to say it's nice she lives in Brooklyn because it's so near. Bye. Nearby. Oh, nearby you. Yes. Oh, nearby you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well, you know, I feel like you did use nearby recently. I probably did. You know, what's the name of that one day in Australia? Oh, yeah, but here's the thing when you forgot to ask her if she spent any time growing up at bun die beach bun die.
咬一口我的三明治。大家，你们现在要用了吗？你刚才是要用“咬（bite）”这个词吗？不，我是想说她住在布鲁克林真好，因为离得那么近。拜。附近（Nearby）。哦，就在你附近。是的。哦，在你附近。对。对。对。好吧，嗯，我觉得你最近确实用过“附近（nearby）”这个词。我可能用过。你知道，澳大利亚那天的名字叫什么来着？哦，对，但问题是，你忘记问她小时候有没有在邦迪海滩（Bondi Beach）呆过一段时间了，邦迪。
Not even the word. That's not right. No, no, not bun die. Bye. Oh, bye. Oh, wait, wait, wait, there this guys, we're back. Who wants it? Who wants it? Sean, you know, bye! Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, SmartLess is 100% organic and artisnally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco and Michael Granterry. SmartLess
连这个词都说不对。那不对。不，不，不是邦迪。拜。哦，拜。哦，等等，等等，等等，各位，我们回来了。谁想要？谁想要？肖恩，你知道的，拜！哦，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，SmartLess由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Granterry百分之百有机手工打造。SmartLess
This episode was recorded on July 7th. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app.
本期节目于7月7日录制。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，您可以在您收听播客的任何地方收听，或者现在就在Amazon Music上提前收听，也可以通过在Apple Podcasts或Wondery App上订阅Wondery Plus来提前收听且无广告。
When we think of sports stories, we tend to think of tales of epic on the field glory. But the new podcast podcast Sports Explains the World brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank. Diving into his Wikipedia page we turn three career goals into eleven, added twenty new
当我们想到体育故事时，我们往往会想到球场上史诗般的辉煌传奇。但全新的播客节目《体育解释世界》（Sports Explains the World）为您带来了一些您从未听过的最疯狂、最令人惊奇的体育故事，比如那个为年轻运动员写了一个假维基百科页面，然后眼睁睁看着一支真正的球队上当受骗的青少年。深入他的维基百科页面，我们将三个职业生涯进球变成了十一个，又添了二十个新的
assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should, have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident? Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous. Each week, sports explains the world. Goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports. And their impact on the world. Goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports. And their impact on the world.
助攻。这些数字本来谁都不该、也不该相信。以及在美国奥运超级巨星在其职业生涯巅峰时期遇害的神秘秘密。这是一场意外吗？警方把调查搞砸了吗？这一切都太模糊了。每周，《体育解释世界》都将超越联赛和数据，分享将重新定义你对体育理解的故事。以及它们对世界的影响。超越联赛和数据，分享将重新定义你对体育理解的故事。以及它们对世界的影响。
Listen to sports explains the world. On the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Wondry App上或您获取播客的任何地方收听《体育解释世界》。您可以在Wondry Plus上提前且无广告地收听《体育解释世界》。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。